[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten Morgen hier
vom Heldenplatz
Nationalfeiertag 2021 wieder in einer
leichten Hybridform und wir sind hier
eine Stunde lang hier auf der sportinsel
wollen hier ein bisschen Ihnen zeigen
was Bundesheer und Sport miteinander zu
tun hat ich habe hier einen prominenten
Gesprächspartner neben mir Andreas on
air
Olympia-Teilnehmer Paralympics in Rio
und in Tokio in Rio 3 Platz herzlich
willkommen hier und
du wirst mit mir hier
diese sportinsel hier durchführen und
du kennst auch natürlich deine Kollegen
hier und du bist Schwimmer
2016 beim Bundesheer ich freue mich dass
ich gemeinsam heute hier seine darf und
werden einige Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aus dem heeresport erkennen lernen ein
bisschen in der sportinsel und durch ihr
schauen die Action Sachen und der
Vorteil war bei Hybrid Veranstaltungen
ist wenn es so herbstliche Temperaturen
sind wie heute damit kann man daheim ein
bisschen schön in in der Wärme sitzen
und trotzdem mitbekommen was das
Bundesheer vor allem in Kombination mit
dem Sport alles so bringen kann und sie
sehen also du bist auch du bist
parasportler das Bundesheer hat seit
wann auch parasportler in aufgenommen
2016 sind wir aufgenommen worden ich war
einer von fünf parano Sports dann die
dabei waren mir fehlt der linke Arm nach
einem Autounfall das hat dazu geführt
dass ich dann im Behindertensport Fuß
gefasst habe die Welt kennengelernt habe
als Sportler Medaille gewonnen habe und
eben seit 2016 das österreichische
Bundesheer auf internationaler Ebene
vertreten darf und seit einem Monat bin
ich auch in Uniform unterwegs denn die
Inklusion ist vorangeschritten und wir
haben weiteren inklusionsschritt gemacht
jetzt bin ich militärperson
militärperson auf Zeit und dafür in
Uniform das Bundesheer auch visuell
repräsentieren und das natürlich eine
große Ehre für mich und schon einen
Stern Herr gebreiter genau auch das ist
schon passiert und wie gesagt für mich
eine große Ehre wunderbar ja das
Bundesheer hat ja nicht nur parashv
sondern auch mehrere Sportler und ist
organisiert in Harrys Leistungszentren
wo die gibt es auf ganz das ganz
Bundesgebiet verstreut gibt den ganz
Österreich und sind teilweise dann
Sportarten Schwerpunkte gesetzt dort wo
er Langlaufen gemacht wird wird dann in
dem Herde Sportzentrum der Fokus aufs
Langlaufen gelegt in meinem
jahressportzentrum haben wir schwimmen
und leichtathletiker als Fokus auch die
zu Drucker sind bei uns im
herdersportzentrum heißt z03 und so gibt
es eben ein ganz Österreicher für unsere
ganzen herdersportlerinnen und her das
Sportler die Heimat wie viele das genau
sind und wie und wo sind wir alles noch
erfahren von den jeweiligen
Verantwortlichen und auf jeden Fall sind
wir eine erfolgreich österreichischer
Sport werden man sich die
medaillenbilanzen anschaut dann kommt
ein Großteil wirklich aus dem heißt der
ich glaube eigentlich fast alle
Medaillen die in Tokio gemacht worden
sind ich glaube bis auf eine Ausnahme
sind wann alles Sportler von heiß
heris-leistungszentren also das ist eine
gute Bilanz richtig und bei den
Paralympics ebenso als auch dort so gut
wie alle Medaillen waren von Paralympics
Athleten aus dem herdersport aber es
zeigt einfach wie wichtig diese
Fördermöglichkeit in Österreich ist
absolut ja hinter uns ist schon jede
Menge Action und wir sehen hier Schüler
das der führungsschule da werden wir
noch der Bundestag die mir für Führung
in Wiener Neustadt weil man noch im
Detail später dazu kommen und die sind
schon voll in Action mit einem Gerät
das hier simuliert paddeln
pro auf den Geräten trainieren unsere
Profis die stehen dort auch schon außer
eine Dame die trainiert nicht auf einem
Plank unsere
drei sind alles Kajak Expertinnen und
Experten wir werden dann auch der
gleiche Ziele gehen und ich sehe das
auch schon die Bewegungen gute sitzen
also das lernt man anscheinend relativ
schnell wir Kollegen aus der Schule
können das schon ganz gut machen ja ich
glaube die haben heute eigentlich damit
angefangen
und wie geht's euch spielt sich schon
was ich gehört habe es soll ein bisschen
weh tun ja
zumindest wird warm und das ist das was
dann hilft der zumindest die
betriebsstemperatur am Laufen zu halten
okay was kann man da genau jetzt
trainieren
[Musik]
für für Abläufe
da bin ich jetzt kein Experte aber ich
nehme mal andere wie bei einem
klassischen Ergometer dass man
Bewegungen simuliert die man so
eigentlich nur auf einem anderen Medium
machen könnte nämlich ein Medium Wasser
und so kann man halt die
kajak-bewegungen schön daheim in der
Wärme machen es kommt wahrscheinlich
nicht ganz auf das spezifische hin aber
trotzdem fürs Trockentraining für ein
Ruderergometer wahrscheinlich gut aber
ich glaube wir gehen dann einfach zu den
Damen und Herren genau wie das ganze
funktioniert und dann machen wir uns
gleich auf den Weg würde ich sagen auf
dem Weg ja wie ich es Gitter so ein
bisschen ich bin alleine muss ich sagen
und es gibt soweit ich weiß Flachwasser
und bildwasser stimmt das das ist glaube
ich korrekt ist korrekt ja und wir haben
hier eine Vertreterin des
okay darf ich denn den Namen
und die Vicky war natürlich wie alle
Sportler hier
auch bei Olympia dabei
und wie ist sie gegangen ja ich bin 11
geworden
war ganz okay war nicht schlecht war
nicht sonderlich gut aber ist schon ein
bin schon zufrieden letztendlich bitte
Elfter Platz in der Weltspitze das ist
doch was
ja nein wie gesagt ich bin wirklich so
im Nachhinein bin ich echt zufrieden und
ja es geht immer besser und in welchem
Hersteller
das Südstadt Südstadt bei für unsere
sehr im Bundesgebiet der südlich von
Wien ist dieses Herz Leistungszentrum
und ja was könnt ihr mit diesem mit
diesen Ergometer speziell hier
trainieren
wird wenn es draußen schon eher kalt
wird und wir machen unsere
Ausdauereinheiten drauf aber auch
Intervalltrainings und ja also sehr
körperlich körperlich anstrengende
Sachen also kann man auch verschiedene
Programme
Fahrens simulieren Wildwasser oder
irgendwelche Parcoure ja man kann die
Intensität vorne regulieren es
Wildwasser kann man ja schlechter
simulieren aber da haben wir dann unsere
Technikeinheiten am Wildwasser
okay gut danke danke Vicky so neben mir
das darf ich dich bitten Dich selbst
vorzustellen ich bin Markus wenn die
Soda bin
flachwasserpadler und war bei den
Paralympics 5
also das ist knapp knapp neben Stockerl
und ja
du bist Flachwasser jetzt also im
Prinzip
das ähnlich wie natürlich Wildwasser
du bist auch in der Südstadt
ich bin heute aus Linz angereist im HLS
hlsz04 in Linz zu Hause
und also wo auch die meisten
flachwasserpadler zu Hause sind alles
ganz seit wann bist du dort
ich war einer der ersten vier A5
parasportlern beim Bundesheer seit 2016
also 1 Oktober 2016 bin ich zum
heeressport gekommen du hast keine
Uniform dann aber du bist auch schon du
hast welchen Dienstgrad ich war bis zu
diesem
ab 1 Oktober bin ich
Gefreiter aber bis jetzt bin ich
amtsassistent okay jetzt vielleicht für
unsere Zuseher auch interessant
herrensportler heißt ja auch dass man
eine
militärische Ausbildung irgendwo auch
machen muss wie war es denn bei dir
diese militärische Ausbildung
ganz normale Grundausbildung gehabt war
total lustig eigentlich hat sehr viel
Spaß gemacht und war ein ja cooles
Erlebnis und wie läuft so jetzt der
Alltag eines herrensportlers es schaut
ja aus wir haben das große Glück dass
wir durch das Bundesheer wirklich
unserem Sport 100%ig nachgehen können
und den wirklich auch professionell
ausüben können und das wird ohne das
Bundesheer einfach auch nicht gehen
und wie ist das jetzt am Wochenbeginn
kommt ihr in das Herz Leistungszentrum
in der Früh da gibt es wahrscheinlich
standeskontrolle wie das heißt im
Bundestag genau wir haben ganz normal
eine standeskontrolle immer in der Früh
wo wir dann angemessen was wir den
ganzen Tag machen was wir trainieren
werden wo wir trainieren werden damit
das auch schön nachvollziehbar ist und
dem folgen wir dann alles klar so da ist
noch ein mich in die Mitte
Hallo ich bin auf Felix oschmannz und
ich mache Cano Slalom und war heuer bei
den Olympischen Spielen IV
knapp ja seit wann bist du herrisch
Sportler ich bin seit 2018
herrersportler und ja ab da was im Film
wie möglich nachher direkt nach der
Schule im herrensport einzusteigen und
einfach mehr Sport professionell
nachzugehen und er war vor weiterhin
Jahre Sportler zu bleiben und in welchen
Zentrum bist du stationiert ich bin im
HLS z07 das ist in Kärnten in Faak am
See und ja das ist für mich absolut der
perfekte Standort da habe ich gutes
Flachwasser zum Trainieren gutes
Wildwasser und bin noch in der Heimat
also das ist für mich perfekte Kombi
also du trainierst sowohl auf
Flachwasser und genau und aus einem
Wildwasser genau das kann man sich
glaube ich so mit Fußball ganz gut
vergleichen mache Trainings müssen ohne
Ball stattfinden und das ist bei uns
dann einfach am Flachwasser mal gewisse
körperliche fitnesszug herzustellen und
ja die technischen Dinge am Wildwasser
dürfen natürlich nicht fehlen also man
braucht einfach gute Kombi
okay was sind aber nächsten Pläne jetzt
so was
natürlich ein großes Jahr gewesen mit
Paralympics oder Olympics wie geht es
jetzt weiter was sind die nächsten
großen Wettkämpfe die als anstehen bei
uns ist Oktober ist meistens frei weil
wir halt das ganze Jahr von uns
vorbereiten und Saison haben am ersten
November geht dann das Training voll
wieder los und wir haben nächstes Jahr
Europameisterschaft und der
Weltmeisterschaft deswegen ja ich bin
jetzt schon total motiviert und freue
mich schon meine nächste Woche nachher
loslegen kann sehr gut und bei dir
ich fange jetzt Abend November wieder
zum Trainieren an und Wettkämpfe also
die ersten großen Gängen erst wieder im
Milos also mit Weltcups und
Europameisterschaft und
Weltmeisterschaft dann im August
bei dir weiter ich habe den gleichen
Plan wieder
Felix in deiner Training
sgruppe weil ich habe
es nächstes mal wieder eine lange Saison
und voll motiviert definitiv wunderbar
ja und wie geht's unseren Schülern hier
die haben gute Kondition wie man sieht
der macht das jetzt schon ja
Viertelstunde zehn Minuten seid ihr
schon werden aus den Jungs noch ja ich
muss sagen es ist auf jeden Fall schon
besser als vor zehn Minuten also die
haben da echt Talent und vielleicht
kommen Sie mal zum Training
was für
Gesetze in der Schule die Sports ja doch
sehr intensiv betreibt was ist denn dein
so schwerpunktsport
ich habe in der Schwerpunkt Sport in der
Schule gewählt die militärischen 5 Kampf
das sind halt die militärischen
Disziplinen von militärischen dabei zum
Beispiel Fechten schwimmen die hip die
Parcours
sowie schießen und Ausdauerlauf
sehr gut wir kommen ja zum militärischen
Fünfkampf
da haben wir noch einiges bis sie
vorbereitet so etwas spannend ja das ist
sehr amagiert darf ich noch deinen Namen
erfahren ja Tennis Dominik motori und du
bist in welcher in welchem Lagern ich
bin jetzt im zweiten Jahrgang der
bergführung gesichert sehr gut du machst
Motorrad an
ich würde mal sagen 2025 okay alles Gute
dafür gell und weiter machen so und
sonst unseren Kollegen da welche
Sportarten machst du normal
habe
und motocrossing Enduro also Kajak
fahren das ist eigentlich schon Profi
hier wie man wie man gehört hat und bist
auch im dritten Jahrgang ich bin gerade
im zweiten Jahrgang also ist noch ein
bisschen länger zur Matura und die
gefällt euch in der Schule
ich gehe mal gerne am Sonntag ins
Internat und ja am Freitag freuen wir
auch schon zu Hause aber ich freue mich
auch wieder am Sonntag wenn ich wieder
reinkommen und meine Kameraden zu sehen
wunderbar wer willkommen dann noch zu
einem eigenen Einstieg noch einmal zur
Schule da werden uns ein bisschen
genauer dann über die schulunterhalter
[Musik]
mal und ich schaue mal wie weit sie
nächste Station ist
sie warten auf uns
[Musik]
dorthin gehen wir haben die Qual der
Wahl ich glaube der Hindernis parkour
ist unsere nächste Station
Hindernisparcours okay dann machen wir
uns auf den Weg dann machen wir uns auf
den Weg
so
die Kollegen stehen bereit
und
wir sind hier bei der Station
Hindernisbahn
das heißt hier geht es um den
militärischen Fünfkampf und die
hindernisbahnen im normalerweise schaut
es ein bisschen anders aus
soweit ich weiß weil die 500 Meter
stimmt das 500 Meter lang 20 Hindernisse
stimmt genau
irgendwann mal schon erlebt
und sogar selber gestehe ich war das
selber auch Soldat lange Zeit sogar
selber drüber gelaufen
habe ich schon länger her ja und das was
Sie hier sehen und was sie ihr uns jetzt
vorführen wird schaut ihr natürlich ein
bisschen anders aus ist etwas ganz was
Neues ja das hat sie glaube ich erst
einmal gezeigt beim Tag des Sports und
hier erst das zweite Mal und ja was kann
man hier simulieren
naja grundspielerischen Kenntnisse des
Sports Koordination natürlich auch den
Spaß an der Bewegung und vor allem heute
ist rutschig auch noch das macht das
Ganze noch ein bisschen lustiger und ja
ja und wir sind hier natürlich lauter
erfahrene militärische Fünfkämpfer der
Fünfkampf damit er schon Fünfkampf hatte
in Österreich eine lange Tradition die
österreichischen militärischen
Fünfkämpfer waren da höchster
erfolgreich oder sind höchster
erfolgreich
ich glaube wann war das nicht so lange
her eine zweite Platz in der bei der
Weltmeisterschaft in der Staffel
und Weltmeister hat es auch gegeben
2016/2016 raus
und ja dann würde ich sagen ein bisschen
den Namen mein brauche ich noch
Baumgartner Baumgartner veit und du bist
einer der neuen jungen Hoffnungen im
militärischen Fünfkampf
und
ja wie schaut
ist also hier geht es um Vielseitigkeit
und
vielleicht die grundlegenden Kenntnisse
dahinter ist natürlich einige
Hindernisse dabei die so ähnlich sind
wie bei uns natürlich haben wir es nicht
aus Luft sondern was Beton meistens und
Holz aber die Grund die grundlegenden
Gegebenheiten sind eigentlich relativ
ähnlich ihr seid die Kinder einfach mal
kennenlernen wie das ist über einen zum
laufen auch wenn es nicht direkt der
militärische ist und die Kinder sind
sehr von der Schule her die wir hier
gleich in Action sehen werden ja dann
würde ich sagen schauen wir uns mal dass
wir hier ein bisschen Dynamik haben
vielleicht das an Andreas vielleicht
kannst du die Kinder noch mal motivieren
durch den Parkour laufen dürft jawohl
wir sind absolut motiviert und freuen
uns schon auf dem Parkour wisst ja auch
was ich erwartet oder ist das jetzt eine
überraschungskiste für euch aber mehr
oder weniger ist es teilweise bekannt
wir sind fünf Kämpfer großteils somit
ist es der Parcours nicht unbekannt ja
mal schauen wird und vor allem seid ihr
mit den Profis die auch beim Bundesheer
sind kann man sich da auch wirklich dann
meine begrüßen natürlich anders als im
Wettkampf selbst aber kann sich da
vielleicht trotzdem einen Griff
abschauen oder einen Sprung Abstand geht
oder was glaube ich ja also ich glaube
Kollege fehlinger ist motiviert und wenn
er alle nur die halbe Motivation von ihm
haben dann sollte es auf jeden Fall
dynamisch werden und actionreich werden
dann würde ich sagen zeig uns mal was
und wir legen los oder wir legen los ja
dann
normalerweise gibt es eine Stadt mit
scharpistole ich sage jetzt einmal
einfach und
sind noch diskutiert werden zuerst darf
gut jetzt haben wir die ersten
Freiwilligen so WWW bei der normalen
Hüpfburg natürlich ohne Schuhe das ganze
so und jetzt geht's los hier meine
Herren auf die Plätze fertig los
so
sind sie mal verschwunden
auf die Plätze fertig los
[Musik]
hat schon seine Tücken
und da geht die Luft kurz raus
keine Sorge wird von uns wieder
hergerichtet
und der zweite Parkour wird auch schon
belaufen worauf kommt es an bei solchen
Parcours was muss man machen auf jeden
Fall
körperstahlabilität man braucht eine
gewisse Grundkarte die Nation
und natürlich Fitness
und das Dinge die hier auch bewusst im
Training dann so umsetzt damit ihr bei
jedem Parcours sofort performen kannst
oder kommt es dann wirklich auf den
Parcours an es kommt auf den Balkon
drauf an wie ich meine möchte denn wir
haben prinzipiell verschiedene Parcours
in der Schule selbst haben wir immer den
gleichen habe ich hier zum Beispiel ist
es nach einer ein anderer wenn
militärischen 5 Kampf ist es ja auch
renommiert das heißt man hat die
gleichen Hindernisse was sind denn die
größten Herausforderungen für dich
das ist einmal leider der Graben die
Grube und der irische Tisch
wie geht man deine Vorbereitung
ineinander man weiß was man alles so
machen muss so geht's aber genau
Wiederholung oder geht es dann um die
spezifischen Fertigkeiten die man sich
anarbeiten muss im Wettkampf selber ist
das Aufwärmen sehr wichtig
ansonsten so oft wie wiederholen wie
möglich und natürlich die Technik können
das heißt auch hier macht Übung den
meisten so wie im Sport überall und wir
sind ja militärischen Fünfkampf sehr
erfolgreich was sind denn deine Ziele
wenn der Ziele für den 5 Kampf sind
wettkampfstechnisch mal
der österreichischen Schläger mal hoch
zu kommen
und mal schauen wie es weitergeht wie
sehr kann man wirklich von anderen
lernen und sich was Abstand geht das
immer da schon fünf Kampf dass man beim
gemeinsamen trainieren auch wirklich
voran kommt und
mitbekommt wie die anderen das machen
oder hängt das wirklich auf die eigenen
Technik dann immer ab also im Fünfkampf
funktioniert das perfekt dass man von
anderen lernen kann wir haben einen
Trainer der echt Spitzenklasse ist und
von denen kann man wirklich sehr viel
lernen das heißt auch hier
[Musik]
das heißt die militärischen Werte dass
man gemeinsam seine Ziele erreicht kann
man hier auch ausleben herzlichen Dank
danke und den zweiten Parcours auch
schon bewältigt oder noch nicht
steht auf jeden Fall jetzt gleich noch
an deine Kollegen sind auch schon bereit
und ich würde sagen den zweiten Parcours
sind dann andere Sachen gefragt oder
genau worauf kommt es am 2.0
die will ich noch nicht nur die bin ich
doch nicht durchgegangen
also müsste man ein bisschen mehr
klettern als beim ersten ein bisschen
klettern auf jeden Fall und bei den
Stäben sieht man bei diesen Stangen es
kommt auch auf Geschicklichkeit an das
heißt neue Faktoren die hier dazu kommen
vielleicht noch zur
Hindernisbahn wie sie Natur ist die
Hindernisse haben ja ganz Animationen
diese irische Tisch wie hoch ist der
das weiß ich nicht genau aber ich
schätze mal auf zwei Meter 30 okay und
die da gibt's auch die Grube die Grube
die ist etwa 18,30 tief okay
vielleicht sogar etwas tiefer
und da braucht man auf jeden Fall gute
dazu dass man die Welt legen kann 500
Meter natürlich mit sie sind 20 in Essen
die sind natürlich wirklich Kräfte
raubend und vor allem dieser
rhythmuswechselt immer da und hat sind
ja auch Hindernisse dabei wo man
balancieren muss wo man
Geschwindigkeit zurücknehmen muss wenn
ich das also diese dieser Wechsel dieser
kondensiver Wechsel ist das interessante
bei diesem Wettkampf ja und schauen uns
das an weil diesem zweiten Durchgang
wenn deine deine Kollegen wieder bereit
sind dass wir
hier ein bisschen Action sehen wunderbar
danke dann darf ich bitten sehr gut los
geht's
dann gebe ich euch staatssignal okay auf
die Plätze fertig los
wie ist das eigentliche Startsignal
Pfeifen oder eine Sirene für gewöhnlich
ist das so eine Klappe da steckt da
schlägt man zu auf die Plätze fertig los
klatschen kann ich jetzt nicht aber dann
machen wir das mit auf die Plätze fertig
los und das zeigt Kameraden sind noch
die bereitstehen
werden noch die Schuhe für die anderen
Kollegen bereitgelegt und dann geht's
los mit der letzten Runde und dann
fragen wir auch schon die Kameraden die
durchgelaufen sind wir sind gegangen ist
schon nicht gewesen sein hoffe ich mal
ja ein bisschen also schon gebraucht bis
sie rübergekommen sind mal schauen wie
es kameradenmotor jetzt geht
da muss da natürlich auch sagen dass das
nicht alles finden könnte hier also
nicht alle Kollegen sind dann auch
aktiven militärische 5 Kämpfer machen
wir eine Startsignal auf die Plätze
fertig los
vielleicht noch anmerken dass wir alle
freiwillig hier sind das heißt natürlich
niemand jetzt extra dafür trainiert
sondern alle aus dem Training und nicht
als Wettkampf zu sehen also soll auch
nur zeigen welche Fertigkeiten
vorbereitet werden in der Ausbildung im
Sport und mit welchen Fähigkeiten man
dann wirklich auch gemeinsam in den
Erfolg gehen kann ich glaube auch ein
Element ist weil es erinnert ja ein
Hüpfburg irgendwo das Spielerische
Elements sollte natürlich auch nicht zu
kurz kommen und wir wissen vom Tag der
Schulen wo das ist erstmal eingesetzt
worden ist das bei Kindern unheimlich
gut angekommen ist und die so gar nicht
los zur eisenwand von diesem
Hindernisparcours also schaut gut aus ja
danke auf jeden Fall danke schön ja dann
schauen wir was wir an weitere Insel
hier
auf jeden Fall schauen wir mal wie
geht's wir machen wieder eine kleine
Wanderung einen Wechsel
ich sehe Philipp Bernina
das Gesicht kenne ich von irgendwoher
ja
ein
sehr nicht nur fünf Kämpfer sondern du
kommst eigentlich von einer
Leichtathletik weil du warst einer der
großen
Speerwerfer wenn ich das in Erinnerung
habe du warst ja
schon lange nicht mehr aber du bist also
in einer sehr erfolgreichen
fünf Kampfmannschaft und bis zur Senior
geworden nicht weil doch einige deine
Kollegen
dann demnächst anderes vor also die
alten werden mehr oder weniger
aussortiert falls man das so hart sein
kann und ja ich glaube aber wir haben
akutes Team und für die zukünftigen
Jahre schaut es nicht schlecht aus
stehen wir glaube ich nicht schlechter
also ich tue mich jetzt outen ich bin
dem Fünfkampf ja auch ein bisschen
verbunden seit vielen Jahren und ja eine
neue junge Mannschaft
eine junge Mannschaft der und du bist ja
glaube ich sogar beim letzten in dieser
Saison einer der großen Rookies
geehrt worden
habe ich gewonnen Newcomer of the Year
oder Newcomer bei den bei welchen bei
welchen großen Wiener Neustadt Turnier
international ah ja also dann Newcomer
bei Mercedes
wunderbar dann wünsche ich euch viel
Glück was ist nächste große Wettkampf
nächstes Saison und nächstes Jahr wird
es dann ab April la mal losgehen mit
kleineren Meetings hoffentlich auch
wieder mehr internationale Beteiligung
Corona bedingt wenn man noch sehen ist
dann wirklich ausschaut aber nächstes
Jahr wieder auf jeden Fall die WM
geplant sein einmal und wir hoffen
natürlich der Stadt findet man muss ja
sagen mein militärischer Fünfgang ist
sehr viel Sportart aber es ist eine
schwerpunktsportart im Bundesheer die
also hier extra gefördert wird je auch
andere Sportarten wie Fallschirmspringen
schießen und so weiter und gehört das
dann auf der militärische Fünfkampf dazu
und
hier sind denn die stärksten Nationen im
Augenblick im militärischen Fünfkampf
normalerweise ist das meistens China
Brasilien ist auch immer wirklich stark
mit dabei Russland zum Teil Weißrussland
das sind eigentlich die drei anfechter
immer auf dem auf dem Titel bei der
Weltmeisterschaft aber man muss sagen
die österreichische Schlagzeug immer
ganz locker und und toll dabei und bin
wieder ein Turnier in Wiener Neustadt
ist ich kann unsere Zuschauer herzlich
einladen was Wiener Neustadt zu kommen
wenn wir das mal Thesen Turnier ist so
die Sport wird neben mir was ihr seid
von ihm mal vor wir sind vom
Orientierungslauf wir sind die Kollegen
von den fünf Kämpfern
im selben Sportzentrum stationiert ich
glaube das ist sebenstein oder genau ja
und hier haben auch eine der Schwerpunkt
statt Sportarten die extra gefördert
werden
und was habt ihr für Wettkämpfe dieses
Jahr gehabt
ja also das war einiges am Plan
angefangen hat international mit an
Weltcup in der Schweiz
dann ist weitergegangen mit ich glaube
dann war eh schon die WM in Tschechien
dann war einer Weltcup in Schweden und
in Italien und
jetzt sag mir mal deinen Namen erfahren
Leo Holper und wir hast du abgeschnitten
so wie seine Saison gelaufen besetzt
angefangen hat im Frühjahr ganz gut also
ich bin da als erste Jahr jetzt in der
allgemeinen Klasse und habe mich sehr
gefreut wie mich für an Weltkrieg in
Schweden qualifizieren habe können bei
nett damit gerechnet habe und
zwar ganz okay
so ich glaube zu dir kommen du bist der
Nikolaus Kastner
deine Saison ja meine Saison war nicht
ganz so wie erhofft ich hätte gern
Weltcup Punkte gemacht das war das große
Ziel ist sich knapp nicht ausgegangen
aber ich glaube dennoch es geht in die
richtige Richtung und darauf kann man
aufbauen ja für Leute die nicht wissen
Orient lauft ihr schon nicht gehört
haben das heißt ihr seid gefordert
erstens mal athletisch ausläuferisch ich
bewegt euch jetzt und nicht auf der
Laufbahn sondern im Gelände und ihr habt
sie Aufgabe mit einer Spezialkarte euch
im Gelände zu orientieren und da einen
Parcours abzulaufen genau und das ist
eben das Interessante dabei es ist eben
nicht nur der physische Aspekt also
nicht nur die die Ausdauerleistung die
wir erbringen müssen sondern eben auch
nebenbei im Kopf bei der Sache sein
konzentriert die Karte lesen richtig
interpretieren und ja anhand dessen was
man dann da heraus liest die Route
entscheiden und hoffentlich die
schnellste finden ich schon vorgekommen
dass ich da ein und Jungs Läufer verirrt
hat ja das ist sicher das passiert jedem
einmal okay und dann hoffen wir halt
dass man irgendwo wieder einen Weg
findet
aus dem aus dem Wald oder aus dem
Gelände irgendwo herauszukommen ja
sicher also in bei wenn man es auf dem
hohen Niveau betreibt sollte es
hoffentlich nie passieren oder sehr
selten aber vor allem am Anfang hofften
wir dann wirklich dass man wieder
rauskommt weil das kann sehr oft
passieren dass man da einen großen
Fehler macht wo man dann neben mir was
wo man ist aber eben wem auf einen hohen
Niveau eher nicht und da gibt es ja auch
verschiedene Strecken Streckenlängen und
es gibt auch Stapel Wettbewerbe ja genau
also bei uns gibt es
grundsätzlich Wettbewerbe im Wald und
sehr oft in der Stadt oder im
Parkgelände
Sprint Wettkämpfe die mit 12 bis 15
Minuten Siegerzeit sind dann gibt es
noch Mittel Distanz im Wald das ist so
ca 35 Minuten sie gezeigt und der lang
ist dann
die ist auf 100 Minuten Siegerzeit
ausgelegt ca und bei den Damen ca 75 bis
ja wir haben schon gesprochen über die
vergangenen Saison wie schaut euer Plan
für die kommende Saison gibt es auch
fitkämpfe im Winter
naja die richtige internationalste
Saison geht erst so im Mai Juni los aber
es gibt natürlich im Winter
trainingswettkämpfe um mal seine Formel
überprüfen kann und ist einfach wichtig
dass man immer wieder eine Karte in der
Hand hat dass man das nicht verlernt
quasi und ja bei der Sache bleibt die
nächsten Highlights vom Wettkämpfen die
hier anstehen
ja nächstes Jahr gibt es wieder eine
Weltmeisterschaft das ist das große Ziel
sich dazu qualifizieren wird nicht
leicht aber
dafür trainiert man
und bei dir ich bin der nächstes Jahr
bei uns ist ja die WM aufgesplittet in
ein Jahr gibt es das bringt WM und ein
Jahr weit weg da nächstes Jahr als Prinz
und schau dass da was gutes ausschaut
dann wünsche ich euch viel Glück und
viel Spaß natürlich und viel Motivation
und ich schlage vor wir gehen jetzt zur
nächsten Insel und schauen was uns so
erwartet Andreas
alle schon bereit sind
wir haben nämlich mit Michaela volleres
und Magdalena krischaco war zwei
Olympiateilnehmer hier michaela
reparadress hat sogar die Silbermedaille
gemacht
der zuständige für herrensport ist hier
das heißt da können wir sicher mehr über
den Herdes Sport erfahren guten Morgen
herzlichen Dank dass auf der Herr der
Sport wieder so aktiv mit dabei sein
darf und Nationalfeiertag was ist denn
der herrensport ganz genau für alle die
zuschauen und immer wieder fragen warum
Sport und Bundesheer dann so gut
zusammenfassen ja der Sport beim Militär
ist ja ganz essentiell also wenn man
sich die Belastungen anschaut denen
Soldaten und Soldatinnen ausgesetzt sind
dann kann man sehr schnell einmal
nachvollziehen warum Sport wichtig ist
ja also Sport soll vorbereiten um dann
diese Belastungen an diese militärischen
Belastungen die Belastungen bei der
Auftragserfüllung dann zu ertragen das
ist der Grund warum wir Sport machen
damit wir wirklich die
Heranwachsenden Soldatinnen und Soldaten
darauf vorbereiten ja und deswegen passt
der Sport auch so gut ins Bundesheer
hinein und ist dadurch auch Heimat für
viele Erfolge der heimischen
Spitzensportlerinnen und Spitzensportler
wie viele Sportlerinnen und Sportler
sind denn derzeit beim Bundesheer dabei
also wir fördern im Jahr bis zu 450
Bundeswehr Leistungssportlerinnen und
Leistungssportler und wie schon erwähnt
wurde das ist eine eine sehr stattliche
Anzahl das sind momentan 40 verschiedene
Sportarten also 40
bundessportfachverbände denen die
Sportlerinnen und Sportler angehören
und ja hier gibt es natürlich auch was
denn was den Spitzensport betrifft
Parallelen zu Militär weil gerade
Spitzensportler sich in einem Bereich
aufhalten der überdurchschnittlich ist
ja vom von der Leistung her und da ist
man schon gewissen Belastungen auch
wieder ausgesetzt wie beim Militär indem
er über die eigenen Grenzen hinweggehen
muss ja indem man sich längere Zeit auf
Erfolge vorbereitet genauso wie man sich
längere Zeit auf Einsätze vorbereiten
muss ja das Spitzensport hat gemeint mit
dem Militär dass man die Komfortzone
verlassen muss ja dass man sehr
strukturiert sein muss dass man sehr
fleißig sein muss ja sehr hartnäckig und
die Ziele zu erreichen also da gibt es
sehr viele Parallelen die man im
Spitzensport sieht und dann natürlich
auch beim Militär deshalb ergänzt sich
jetzt dieses
leistungssportmodell mit dem Militär
sehr gut und all diese Werte die passt
noch gut zum behinder Sport und auf der
Behindertensport findet 2016 seine
Heimat im jahressportzentrum ich bin
jetzt auch in Uniform hier seit 1
Oktober auch als militärperson als Zeit
dabei wie passt das dazu
Behindertensport und ja das passt
genauso gut vielleicht noch besser dazu
weil man genau in dem Bereich ja auch
keine Komfortzonen kennt genauso wie im
Regelsport auch und es ist schon etwas
ganz Wichtiges angesprochen worden wir
machen doch gar keine Differenzierung
mehr keine Differenzierung zwischen
Behindertensport und und den Regelsport
das ist ein Sport ja und für unser
absolute Bereicherung ja für uns
natürlich auch eine zeitkristall
Inklusion auch wirklich gelebt wird im
Hintergrund das sind auch schon unsere
erfolgreichen naturdrucker beim
Aufwärmen wenn man so mitbekommt als
Verantwortlicher für all das was im
herdersdorf Sport passiert dass dann die
Athletin und Athleten so erfolgreich
sind und so viele Medaillen bekommen und
ein Großteil der Medaillen bei den
großen Ereignissen wirklich dann von HSZ
Athleten und Athleten gemacht wird wie
stolz ist man dann ja
dem Stolz also es ist bei jeder
Übertragung egal ob das jetzt
Wintersport oder Sommersport ist als
begeisterter Sportler natürlich wenn man
jetzt Kommandant des jahressportzentrums
ist im Speziellen vielleicht auch wie
hört man mit jedem Sportler mit jeder
Sportlerin mit und wenn es dann gelingt
ist man natürlich sehr stolz und wir
wissen alle das ist ja ist ja nicht
selbstverständlich ja ich sage das
meinen sportlichen Sportlern immer
wieder
die Leistung ist extrem hoch aber am Tag
X wenn es darauf ankommt ja kann es sein
dass wenn man ein bisschen Pech hat man
nicht am Stockerl steht sondern fünf
oder siebenter wird ja und wenn es
funktioniert dann stehen heute oben und
und deswegen weiß ich wie da Erfolg und
und ich will nicht sagen Misserfolg aber
der vierte Platz ist halt ein
undankbarer Platz wie eng das
beieinander liegt und wenn es dann
wirklich funktioniert dann freuen wir
uns alle ihre riesig mit ja und bei den
olympischen bzw auch paralympischen
Sommerspielen hat er das super
funktioniert Bayern muss man wirklich
sagen eben bei den Paralympics haben
herrensportler 6 von 9 Medaillen gemacht
bei den Olympischen Spielen sechs von
sieben als in Summe sind es
75%. das heißt wir wollen sehr oft stolz
ja und das zu Recht und wie enger Erfolg
und leider auch Misserfolg oder eben
eine ganz knapp
beieinander liegen das weiß ich was
persönlich Erfahrung aber alles schon
erlebt deswegen kann ich auch die
Emotionen gut nachvollziehen herzlichen
Dank auf jeden Fall dass der Sport hier
die Heimat hat und wir die Erfolge auch
gemeinsam feiern können ja wir haben
hier kühle Temperaturen und wenn ich auf
unsere judokussiert schaue dann glaube
ich die sind dankbar wenn wir sie ein
bisschen bewegen bringen
und ich darf euch einmal bitten zeigt
uns ein bisschen was
ein bisschen Action machen macht euch
warm
es ist Matthias es ist Jack und
Magdalena schon angezogen Michaela
volleres hat sich noch nicht ganz
gemütlich gemacht oder doch gemütlicher
sie kommt dann später dran das heißt sie
wird auch noch im Einsatz sein
was ich schon gelernt habe im Schulter
dass man eben gemeinsam trainieren kann
auch wenn man jetzt nicht in der
gleichen Gewichtsklasse ist auch wenn
man verschiedene
Einsteiger Levels hat oder eben schon
Profis aber vielleicht kommentierst du
uns einfach was die beiden jetzt uns
vorzeigen werden
ja so zuerst einmal ein bisschen
aufwärmen einrollen natürlich damit man
nicht so hart fällt
ja das ist die Rolle vorwärts
natürlich muss man auch die Matte
kennenlernen oder es ist mit dem Reis
wie man richtig auf dieser Matte fällt
ist immer verschieden dann wenn man
seinen Boden einmal kennenlernen muss
oder ja
Matten sind trotzdem jedes Mal anders
und
ja hängt er sich auch von Temperatur und
und Beschaffenheit des Raumes und sowas
das ab ich kann das aus dem Wasser oder
den spricht man vom Wassergefühl und man
denkt sich immer Wasser ist Wasser ja
aber es ist doch immer ganz ganz anders
als hier hier wird wahrscheinlich mit
dem Boden dann genauso sein ja genau und
auch wenn man wir trainieren
normal anders und da muss man trotzdem
mal auf seinem Matte gehen dass man weiß
so okay so schauts dann ist wirklich aus
damit man nicht irgendwie dann
überwältigt ist weil man das erste Mal
drauf geht also was machen wir dir so
Magdalena jetzt schau dass sie tanzen
das heißt kurz Sushi das sind Zugübungen
das machen man zu Beginn dann als
nächstes drehen wir ein und dann
beginnt man erst mit werfen also das
ganz normales aufwärmen
und all das ist zur
Verletzungsprävention damit sich niemand
weh tut damit man schon einmal gut in
den Gelenken geschmiert ist und dann
erst geht das richtig los genau also wie
vor jedem Sport sollte man sich am
besten aufwärmen und das ist beim
Schultern die ich sehr wichtig weil es
dann trotzdem enorme Kräfte was auf dem
Körper wirken und das ist umso wichtiger
dass man lang und gescheit aufwärm
vorher jetzt Hand aufs Herz ich weiß
dass viel Sportarten dass man sich
aufhören sollte aber es nicht immer
gerne gemacht wird wie gerne tut es hier
Aufwärmen vor allem wenn ihr wisst
eigentlich ein richtig viel lieber
werfen oder Bodenkampf üben oder mal die
anderen Sachen machen also es ist das
auch wirklich ein bewusst dass man auf
einmal wirklich einsetzen sollte ja also
uns ist schon eigentlich wirklich
bewusst weil auch wenn ich jetzt gerne
werfen würde ich bin dann auch
irgendwann dran dass ich geworfen werde
und dann wäre natürlich nicht voll kalt
auf die Matte vorhin also deswegen
werden wir uns eigentlich relativ gern
auf und manchmal also im normalen
Heimtraining Bauma so kleine Spielchen
an das seit ein bisschen Challenge da
ist und dass man mehr motiviert ist also
auf einem steht eigentlich eher nur
Wasserstelle jetzt werden schon erste
Würfe gemacht aber es wirkt noch sehr
sehr sanft das würde man den anderen
hinlegen aber das war nicht mehr so sein
ja also
wir kennen schon
jetzt nichts weh für uns ist das ganz
normal
ja vor allem in den Trainingsgruppen in
denen man sich schon besser kennt ist
das auch ein Faktor man weiß wie man den
anderen werfen muss man kennt sich ist
es dann anders wenn man mit mit Fremden
kämpft ja ein bisschen anders ist aber
man spielt sie dann gleich aufeinander
eigentlich und man war es ja man lernt
ja wie man richtig sicher dass also dass
man einfach ohne zum Halten am Boden
fallen lässt so zum Beispiel die Magda
los die man hat ihm unsere wehren den
Griff dass ein bisschen zurück hat und
ja
jetzt sieht man das Mann und Frau
gemeinsam trainieren ist es üblich ist
das
sinnvoll kann man da gegenseitig
voneinander lernen im Kampf ist es dann
doch anders wie läuft das im Training ab
hier in Österreich ist eigentlich schon
üblich dass wir alle gemeinsam
trainieren und es ist finde ja recht
sinnvoll weil wir für die Männer
trotzdem andere Techniken lernen weil
die Kraft und alles ganz anders
übersetzt ist und dadurch
kann ich sehr viel lernen in andere
Länder ist es eher nicht so üblich in
Japan zum Beispiel gar nicht da ist es
strenge Trend da ist aber ich finde wir
machen es ziemlich gut und es passt
super man sich ja ist überhaupt kein
Unterschied
ist deine Olympia silberne ist uns allen
noch gut in Erinnerung wie hast du Tokio
erlebt für alle die jetzt zuschauen und
dann unbedingt einmal wissen wollten wie
dir das alles dort ja wie du das alles
wahrgenommen hast ja also danke aber
unglaublich das war Wahnsinn vor Studio
eben in Japan wo es herkommt zu machen
und im Budokan das ist das war
unglaublich unglaubliches Gefühl und es
war eher dort zum Kämpfen und natürlich
umso besser dann aber Teile zu holen
also es ist übrigens
hast du mitgerechnet war das etwas was
man natürlich hat man das große Ziel
natürlich weiß man wofür man kämpft aber
das ist dort dann wie du gesagt hast im
Heimatland des trudo Sports dass du dann
dort die Medaille machst war das etwas
womit du kalkuliert hast na ja irgendwie
ich habe gewusst das ist möglich aber im
Judo kann halt alles passieren wenn man
Sekunden dann aufpasst
kommt wirft da wirft wieder andere und
deswegen gewusst es wird übers mit
konzentrieren es muss einfach auspassen
an dem Tag und dann kann natürlich man
Teile austauschen aber ich war trotzdem
sehr überrascht wieder im Finale
gestanden bin und das ist auf jeden Fall
großartig gemacht aber volle
Konzentration voller Fokus das sind
militärische Tugenden
worauf es ankommt um wirklich den Erfolg
zu haben und es wird schon wieder auf
der Matte würde ich sagen oder
was haben sie jetzt gerade gemacht also
jetzt kämpft man so spielerisch
eigentlich also es ist noch nicht voller
Kampf sondern auch so eher zum Aufwärmen
zum reinkommen so aus der Bewegung
werfen
eben den Gegner aus dem Gleichgewicht
bringen und
eigentlich mit wenig Kraft zum kämpfen
da effektiv für sein was wirst du dann
später noch machen dass jemand du gehst
dann nachher auf die Matte ja also
später okay für alle die später dann
noch zuschauen auf jeden Fall Michaela
erfordert das heute hier im Einsatz für
das Bundesheer beim Nationalfeiertag
genauso wie matthiascheck und Magdalena
krischakova und also zwei
olympia-teilnehmerinnen hier zu haben
eine Medaille Gewinnerin das ist auf
jeden Fall schon eine große Ehre für den
Schulter Sport absolut absolut ja eine
der Überraschung kann ich jetzt gleich
vorwegnehmen denn im Laufe dieses
Nationalfeiertages haben wir eine
Persönlichkeit hat die also auch mit
Transportern hier
Sport machen wird mir hat sie sehr viel
geholfen in der Pandemie mich zu bewegen
zu Hause wie wir eingesperrt waren Sport
mit viel Pfeilen herzlich willkommen
einen wunderschönen guten Morgen es ist
noch ziemlich frisch aber wir werden
hier schon ein bisschen was tun damit
uns wärmer wird wunderbar du hast das
auch einiges vor mit unseren sporteln
hier ich habe die große Ehre mit
olympia-teilnehmerinnen Olympia
Teilnehmerinnen olympia-teilnehmern
miteingewinnern hier gemeinsam ein
bisschen zu turnen das heißt wir sind
fürs Warmup verantwortlich und es sind
auch alle gerne zu Hause eingeladen bei
uns ein bisschen mitzumachen wunderbar
also Sport mit Philipp auch auf unserem
Livestream von
Nationalfeiertag at und natürlich auch
im ORF auf zwei Sport mit Philipp freut
man sehr drauf wir sind das erste Mal
glaube ich 33 das zweite Mal um 10:10
also Mathe zu Hause herrichten aber es
geht auch im Pyjama oder in der
Unterhose
wunderbar jetzt habe ich ein Bild das
war das wollte ich jetzt das brauche ich
jetzt einige Zeit wieder loszuwerden ja
danke Philipp also einiges was wir hier
noch bieten werden wir werden uns auch
noch im Laufe dieses Tages noch einige
Male hier von dieser sportinsel
melden ja
Andi du bist ein Vollprofi auch als
Moderator hier das erste Mal am
Heldenplatz am Nationalfeiertag in
dieser Funktion in dieser Rolle ja ich
habe natürlich immer wieder
vorbeigeschaut auch in den letzten
Jahren als der Sportler Autogramme
geschrieben beim Nationalfeiertag aber
ist einfach schön zu sehen dass wir so
viele tolle Athletinnen und Athleten
haben die sich dann auch in den Dienst
der Sache stellen und den Sport
präsentieren dass der Bundesheer
repräsentieren und ist auch schön dass
ich mit den meisten von ihnen auch eben
sportpodcast im Sport Report dem Sport
Podcast das ist zwar schon Bundeswehr
schon geredet habe das heißt da die
Geschichten auch herauszuholen und zu
zeigen was diese Menschen schon alles
geleistet haben was sie bewegt was sie
vorantreibt ist einfach eine tolle Sache
und ich habe Bettina blank unsere Kritik
mit allen Gewinnerinnen in Tokio wir
haben mit den kanuttinnen und Kanuten
schon gesprochen auch in meinem parallel
Kollege Mandy Swoboda und all das und
das sieht man das ist Mannschaft das ist
ein Team man kennt sich man mag sich man
unterstützt sich und das ist einfach
schön dass wir diese Werte auch beim
herrensport leben können vielleicht noch
eine
die eigentlich ganz wichtig ist wie wird
man denn herrisch Sportler es gibt zwei
Wege also entweder man nicht so Sportler
ohne Behinderung dann
wird man von seinem Fachverband wenn man
sportliche Leistungen hat und man zu
Grundausbildung zum grundwehrdienste
muss wird man vorgeschlagen und man
macht dann einen Sportler
Grundwehrdienst das heißt man hat die
sechs Wochen Grundausbildung und dann
ihm heißt z macht man sozusagen seinen
Dienst und wenn man dann ein gewisses
Niveau hat so wird man weiter
verpflichtet und je nach sportlichen
Leistungen und Zielsetzungen schafft man
es dann bis zu 15 Jahren im HSZ zu
bleiben oder man ist eben Sportler oder
Sportlerin mit Behinderung und dann
kommt das eben von den sportlichen
Leistung hängt das ab und natürlich ob
derzeit genug Plätze da sind wir sind 20
Athleten und Athleten mit Behinderung
derzeit und es werden natürlich immer
wieder Leute auf dadurch werden Plätze
frei und die werden dann mit jungen
Damen und Herren
nachbesetzt die natürlich Niveau haben
um Medaillen zu machen bei
Weltmeisterschaften Paralympics oder
Europameisterschaften also wichtig ist
dass der zuständige Verband auch eine
Empfehlung macht dass also dieser
Sportler eine gewisse also bereit ist
Leistung zu bringen wie geht es
Kriterium
dass man herrisch Vater bleiben kann ist
ja nicht dass dass man auf Ewigkeit
sondern man muss ja auch Leistung
gebracht werden absolut und es gibt da
eine also Konferenz wo Menschen drin
sitzen die wirklich die Kompetenz auch
haben teilweise aus dem
Sportfachverbänden selbst wenn dort
natürlich die Fachkompetenz ist
natürlich kennen sich die
Verantwortlichen im Bundesheer mit
vielen Sportarten aus und man kann nicht
alles komplett überblicken das heißt man
hat da wirklich die Dinge Zusammenarbeit
mit den Fachverbänden aber natürlich
hier geht es auch darum wer hat noch
potenzialwerkern in Zukunft etwas
bewegen etwas erreichen und vor allem
auch wie viele Plätze gibt es pro
Sportart in dem jeweiligen Jahrgang ist
ja nicht immer gleich es wird auch mal
wieder verändert unsere Nation wird teil
plötzlich zu einer radsportnation und
dann wird dann natürlich dort danach
gebessert bei den Plätzen oder eine
Sportart bringt jetzt seit einigen
Jahren nicht mehr so viel Leistung das
heißt man nimmt verteilt die Plätze dann
wieder um also das ist das lebendig
jetzt bewegt sich es verändert sich und
es wird auch jedes Jahr immer neu
entschieden wie viele Plätze haben wir
wer bleibt da drinnen werden noch
Potenzial und welche neuen Talente
möchte man auf wen nehmen um eben die
Möglichkeit zu bieten den Sport wirklich
als Profi auszuüben und das ist wirklich
wenn man nicht gerade Fußballer ist oder
Skifahrer oder Tennisspieler in
Österreich wirklich die einzige
Möglichkeit seinen Sport auf dem Niveau
abgesichert mit einem Einkommen mit
einer
zukunftsberuflichen Möglichkeit zu
absolvieren und wenn man das nicht
wahrnimmt dann hat man kaumchancen im
österreichischen Sport also das
Bundesheer wirklich eine große Stütze im
österreichischen Sport ja und wenn ich
wenn Sportler ich bin herrischsportler
bringe meine Leistung bin irgendwo da
platziert und dann habe ich in Saturn wo
es nicht so gut läuft was passiert dann
mit mir wenn ich dann ausgeschieden oder
darf ich beim Bundesheer dann bleiben
oder wie läuft das also es ist auf jeden
Fall nicht so dass man sofort rausfällt
es gibt die Möglichkeit dass man als
verletzte gilt es wird dann immer wieder
evaluiert wir stehen die Chancen auf ein
Comeback wie stehen die Chancen auf
weitere sportliche Performance ist und
dann wird individuell eine Möglichkeit
gefunden entweder es wieder zu schaffen
oder eben beruflich sich weiterzubilden
es gibt das System der Berufsförderung
im Bundesheer das heißt alle
jahressportlerinnen und herrensportler
die eine gewisse Dauer beim HSZ dabei
waren werden dann beruflich unterstützt
man bekommt dann einen Teil seines
Gehalts fortgezahlt und eine Ausbildung
wird einem ermöglicht oder die
Möglichkeit eben selbst im Bundesheer
weiter beruflich tätig zu bleiben so wie
bei uns
behindertensportlerinnen und
Behindertensportler also da wird auf
jeden Fall auch einen geschaut und
natürlich gibt es auch Verletzungen wo
man später nicht mehr olym gewinnen wird
aber auch da wird eben so eine Lösung
dann gefunden also ich glaube das
Wichtige ist unsere Sportler sind also
versorgt und vor allem auch also
abgesichert
und das ist glaube ich macht eine
Sportler schon sicher ich schaue jetzt
auf die Uhr weil
wir ja noch im wir haben noch ein
bisschen Zeit weil es geht ab 9 Uhr ja
dann weiter auf der Bühne mit dem
Programm sowohl hier am Livestream also
ich darf sie auch einladen sie sehen
hier am Livestream einiges was sie im
ORF nicht sehen sie sind am Rolf
Zeit und einige Sachen die sie nicht im
Livestream sind sie können entscheiden
was für sie interessante ist auf jeden
Fall wir bleiben mit unserem Programm
natürlich hier am Platz
aber sie versäumen weder dort noch hier
das Wesentliche also das Wesentliche ist
der nationalvertrag die Angelobung von
100 Rekruten der Garde halt das
Highlight im Beisein der Bundesregierung
vorher die grenzenjägung des
Bundespräsidenten und der
Bundesregierung in der Krypta also wir
haben ein normales
nationalvertragsprogramm leider
natürlich ohne die vielen
tausend zusehen die wir haben
halt als Hybrid aber bleiben sie auch zu
Hause so kann es nichts zum Heldenplatz
sie ist hier alles abgesperrt also sie
sehen auch nichts es ist auch ein
Sichtschutz weil es eine
geschlossene Veranstaltung ist eine
2g-plus-veranstaltung das heißt nur mit
Anmeldung und mit der Einladung
können Sie an diese Veranstaltung
teilnehmen natürlich sind direkt die
Angehörigen unserer 100 Rekruten die
heute hier angelobt werden hier dabei
ich schlage vor dass wir jetzt eine
kleine Pause machen
und
wir werden uns dann in Kürze wieder
melden danke sehr
[Musik]
Traumlandschaft Zimmer
Ei
[Musik]
an einem schönen Vormittag meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren das was Sie
hier sehen das ist das Showteam der
ersten Garde Kompanie und damit herzlich
willkommen zum Nationalfeiertag
[Musik]
der Nationalfeiertag ein Tag an dem die
immerwährende Neutralität Österreichs
gefeiert wird und ein Tag an dem der
Heldenplatz in der Wiener Innenstadt im
Zentrum steht in diesem mittlerweile
zweiten corona-jahr ist alles anders das
trifft auch auf die zahlreichen
Veranstaltungen zu die in den
vergangenen Jahren am Nationalfeiertag
stattgefunden haben etwa die
Informations- und Leistungsschau des
Bundesheeres am heckenplatz mit dem
Höhepunkt der Angelobung der Rekruten
diese Feierlichkeiten zum
Nationalfeiertag fallen in diesem Jahr
wie schon im vergangenen Corona Jahr
deutlich kleiner aus werden sie deshalb
durch die Höhepunkte begleiten das
erwarten Sie studioanalysen
Live-Berichte und ausführliche
Reportagen aus der Wiener Innenstadt die
Sie bequem zuhause vor dem Fernseher
oder online mitverfolgen können auch das
Bundesheer lädt Sie zu einem virtuellen
heldenplatzbesuch ein unter
www.nationalfeiertag 21.at bei mir im
Studio jetzt darf ich ganz herzlich
begrüßen generalmaier Bruno Günther
Hofbauer danke dass Sie gekommen sind
und unseren Chef der Innenpolitik
Folge sie werden uns durch diesen
Vormittag begleiten mit ihrem fundierten
Hintergrundwissen
ja der Nationalfeiertag
der Wiener Heldenplatz
jedes Jahr ist er der Schauplatz am
Nationalfeiertag für uns vor Ort ist
jetzt Reporterin Saskia venenboss ja wo
normalerweise sehr sehr viel Trubel
herrscht wo sich 10.000 Menschen
versammeln um sich die Informations- und
Leistungsschau des Bundesheeres
anzuschauen da ist es jetzt relativ leer
man sieht keine Menschen oder nur sehr
wenige Saskia was ist denn da heute zu
erwarten sie sind da geplant
nun wie wir sie schon erwähnt haben
heute es dürfen nicht so viele Leute am
Heldenplatz teilnehmen rund 500 werden
hier erwartet darunter Ehrengäste
Mitglieder des Ministers
Verwandte von Angst zu gelobenen und
auch Journalisten was ist heute zu
erwarten als erstes wird jetzt gleich
dann der vorturne der Nation ORF Star
Philipp Jelinek mit Olympioniken des
Bundesheers trainieren und um 9 Uhr wird
es dann traditionell der Bundespräsident
über die Kastanienallee schreiten zur
traditionellen Kranzniederlegung weiters
wird ihm dann die Bundesregierung folgen
dann werden rund als Höhepunkt 100
Rekruten auf der Bühne hinter mir hier
angelobt werden und es folgen Redens der
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
von Bundeskanzler Alexander Schallenberg
Wiens Bürgermeister Michael Ludwig und
vom Bundespräsident Alexander v melden
was sie hinter mir sehen hier gibt es
allerlei Gerätschaft die hier seit
Donnerstag aufgebaut wurde Klaus
Bruckmann war dabei für uns dabei
[Musik]
alljährlich zum Nationalfeiertag wird
der Heldenplatz zu einer großen Bühne
mit vielen Schauplätzen der Aufbau geht
rasant 600 Meter Absperrgitter samt
Sichtschutz werden aufgestellt
am Donnerstag ist die Bühne auf der die
rund 100 Ehrengäste stehen werden noch
nicht aufgebaut das konnte erst
geschehen als die beiden Hubschrauber
gelandet waren
auf dem Platz auf dem die anzugelobenen
100 Rekruten stehen ist Ende letzter
Woche noch kaum etwas zu sehen lediglich
an den Rückwänden wurde fleißig
gearbeitet gestern war alles weitgehend
fertig
hinter der Bühne mit den Rekruten stehen
einige heeresfahrzeuge ein gepanzerter
Dingo
ein Radpanzer Pandur
und ein Schützenpanzer olan
auch ein mobiles Radar mit 26 Tonnen
Gewicht ist gestern Vormittag
eingetroffen
[Musik]
die Militärpolizei bereitet sich auf
ihren Einsatz
vorm vorne im Bereich der Straßen und
beim zu Marsch der ehrenkompany und dann
bereit da schauen dass das dann geklärt
ist wenn wir einer können zu sehen gibt
es auch einen Hindernisparcours den
Schüler des militärgymnasiums in Wiener
Neustadt absolvieren werden
ein dichtes Programm leider nur virtuell
fleißig geprobt damit am
Nationalfeiertag auf dem Heldenplatz
alles nach Plan abläuft
fit mach mit ist ja auch ein
Motto des
Nationalfeiertags seit 1962 fördert das
österreichische Bundesheer den
Leistungssport da jetzt derzeit sind
rund 450 Leistungssportler in diesem
Programm und sie nehmen für Österreich
an Europameisterschaften
Weltmeisterschaften Olympischen Spielen
und Paralympics Teil vier dieser
Medaillengewinner sind jetzt hier mit
unserem Vorturner Philipp Jelinek bereit
und zwar sind Michaela Polaris Bettina
Plank Viktoria Wohlfahrt und Felix
oschmautz bitte Philipp einen
wunderschönen guten Morgen Österreich
wir sind heute schon einmal vollzählig
angetreten mit den olympiasportlerinnen
und olympiosportlern schön dass ihr
Zuhause mit dabei seid und die Damen und
Herren die Lust und Laune haben können
gleich einmal einsteigen und zwar am
Stand zu gehen und dabei den Kniehub zu
aktivieren worauf wir aber achten ist
das heißt rechtes Knie linke Handflächen
umgekehrt warum sage ich das sieht man
auch oftmals anders
und das Schöne ist wenn man aktiv in
einen Tag startet fühlt man sich auch
wesentlich besser so wir ziehen schön
nach oben wie gesagt da hinten gut
jawohl diese motiviert ihr zu Hause
hoffentlich auch so nächster Schritt wir
versuchen unsere Knie nach oben zu
ziehen und mit unseren Knien unsere
Handflächen zu berühren genau da gehen
wir richtig schön nach oben ja
ausgezeichnet Einsteiger voneinander
unten an fortgeschrittene ein bisschen
weiter nach oben und die Profis ziehen
richtig schön nach oben sehr schön okay
und jetzt nehmen wir noch den
Schultergürtel mit das heißt wir haben
da die Rotation genau und versuchen auch
da rechts links unsere Knie zu berühren
sehr schön Einsteiger da unten
fortgeschritten und dann können wir uns
steigern super so nächster Schritt
unser Anfersen das heißt die Einsteiger
beginnen eine ganz ganz locker man kann
sich auch gerne irgendwo anhalten wenn
es sein soll und die Profis sie können
ein bisschen mehr Schwung aufnehmen
richtig und Geld zu versuchen wir rechts
links zack nehmen wir ein bisschen
Kontakt auf genau rechts links einmal
richtig schön nicht zu schwingen
aber super genau und für die Damen und
Herren zu Hause die Einsteiger ganz
locker zunächst beginnen und dann kann
man das ganze in den Schwung voller
gestalten und worauf es noch ankommt ist
natürlich ja der nächste Schritt ja
nächste Schritt wir versuchen ja
anzufassen das heißt ja ich drehe mir
ganz kurz um für euch ja
aufpassen aber beim Anfersen damit man
es leider nicht auf die Fingerspitzen
klopfen weil das kann ziemlich weh tun
und auch da können wir uns dynamisch
bewegen rechts links wir lassen die
Atmung fließen da hinten ist schon auch
ganz gut aus sie kommen mal zu euch ja
kann euch ein bisschen Action sein meine
Damen und Herren
olympiasportlerinnen und Sportler genau
Lächeln aufsetzen das ist gut so
motivierte den Tag zu starten und jetzt
versuchen wir das ganze diagonal das
heißt
linke Fußsohle rechte Handfläche der
Fingerspitzen trenne ich wieder mal um
damit man es besser sieht ja sehr schön
und worauf kommt es beim Sport generell
an auch bei der Bewegung es ist die
Regelmäßigkeit oder die macht den Erfolg
deswegen ist es ganz ganz wichtig
einfach dran zu bleiben die
möglichkeiten dazu gibt es immer Montag
bis Freitag in ORF 2 und kurz nach 9 Uhr
ja können sie mitnehmen Schnitt 17
Minuten 30 und gehen wir haben die
Dynamik mit dabei sehr schön rechts
links Kamera ein bisschen schwungvoller
machen
wir wieder zurück ins Studio zu dir
Rebecca das hat sehr gut ausgeschaut
vielen Dank ernst weil ihnen Boss und
Philipp Jelinek wir schalten später dann
wieder zu euch das Zentrum des heutigen
Tages ist zwar der Heldenplatz aber wir
beginnen am Ballhausplatz im
Bundeskanzleramt der Tag der offenen Tür
ist Corona bedingt abgesagt Reporterin
Gabi Conrad nimmt sie deshalb mit auf
einer informative Runde durch das
Bundeskanzleramt schönen Vormittag Gabi
Konrad was ist denn da heute alles
geplant
statt der tausenden Besucher die sonst
am Tag der offenen Tür
ja wir sind hier wieder im helmplatz
wieder hier auf der sportinsel und wie
ich schon vorher gesagt habe wir werden
uns jetzt im anderen Schwerpunktthema
widmen wir haben Sie bei unserem ersten
Einstieg schon gesehen unsere Schüler
hier in Reihe aufgestellt wie beim
Militär und es ist ja hat ja viel mit
Militär zu tun diese Schule für höhere
Führung und neben mir steht major Haas
von dieser Schule
und ich habe es ein
barettfarbe die man vielleicht nicht so
kennt vielleicht fangen wir mal mit
dieser Farbe an
ja schönen guten Morgen ja zu unserer
barrettfarbe die Schule für Führung und
Sicherheit in Wiener Neustadt disloziert
an der thermillac und daher auch die
barettfarbe den das baretta sich trage
ist die neue barettfarbe für gar nicht
so lange her eingeführt und ganze
Termine
weil der Milak ist beim Bundesheer
gebräuchlich aber uns findet unser zu
sehr
kennenzul das Bundesheer aber so die
Begrifflichkeiten sind nicht so vertraut
also ihr seid seine Schule im Rahmen der
thermischen militärkremie und es hat
eigentlich eine ich sagte sie mal so
eine ganz normale Schule wo man mit
Matura abschließt genau das sind wir wir
sind eine Handelsakademie also
fünfjährige Form die Kinder beginnen bei
uns in der Oberstufe sind dann die fünf
Jahre bei uns da was macht uns dann
besonders das ist eben diese
schulspezialisierung Führung und
Sicherheit das heißt wir selektieren da
schon ein bisschen aus wir suchen uns da
die Führungskräfte der Zukunft und die
wollen wir natürlich auch fördern dass
sie sich entsprechend entwickeln und
hoffen natürlich dass sie dann bei uns
beim Bundesheer bleiben und auf die der
dasianische Militärakademie dann weiter
wechseln also die Schüler wollen schon
selber auch Führungskräfte werden und
bewerben sich also wenn nicht jetzt
hingezwungen Führungskräfte zu werden
sondern die wollen natürlich auch selber
führen ja natürlich das wollen sie das
ist einmal ein Anspruch den Sie an sich
selbst stellen und sehr viele machen das
auch und wir sind sehr stolz auf unsere
Katheten auf das was sie jetzt schon
leisten ja der Schulalltag in dieser
Schule der ist natürlich ein bisschen
anders wie in einer anderen Schule in
ein anderer Handelsakademie wie schaut
es denn so aus sein ein Stundenplan
eines Tages
das beginnt bei uns mit einem Tagwache
ruft den 50% unserer Schüler sind ja
auch bei uns im Internat das heißt über
Nacht auch da das heißt so wie die
Soldaten dann auch geht es in der Früh
mit Tagwache aus dem Bett hinunter in
den Speisesaal zum Frühstück bis dann um
8 Uhr Gericht beginnt und das spezielle
bei uns ist dann noch einmal in der
Woche der wahlsport und einmal in der
Woche dann auch noch die außerschulische
Ausbildung hier ist dann das Bundesheer
im Vordergrund wo wir auch unser ganzes
Fachwissen das auch das Bundesheer hat
und da gerade die Theresianische
Militärakademie auch den Kindern zur
Verfügung stellen ja Sports ist auch ein
wesentliches Element haben wir schon
gesehen
wie stellt man sich dieses militärische
Element jetzt vor was was passiert da
das beginnt bei ganz einfachen
militärischen Basisthemen das heißt wenn
unsere Schüler so kommen so wir haben
jetzt auch welche dabei von der ersten
Klasse die beginnen auch wirklich einmal
mit Exerzierdienst das ganze Umfeld
Kennenlernen über kartengelände Kunde
Fernmeldedienst mit auch den Funkgeräten
des Bundesheeres
truppenbesuche wo wir uns auch wirklich
das bundesheeran seine
Leistungsfähigkeit vorstellen das geht
aber dann in Zukunft mit dem beginnen
wir mit den ältesten jetzt sagen aber
auch schon in die Taktik in den
Stabsdienst also alles was man in einem
modernen Umfeld braucht dass sich mit
Sicherheit beschäftigt in unserem Land
ja und wir haben also hier lauter Buben
wenn man aber auch ein Mädchen dabei wie
schaut es denn aus
wie viel meters hat sie es in der in
dieser Schule
das was hier da steht ist nicht der
Zustand den wir in der Schule haben den
wir haben viel mehr Mädchen ja es ist
jetzt nur eine da aber zum zum Beispiel
bei den ersten Klassen die jetzt
begonnen haben haben wir fast 50 Prozent
Mädchenanteil also wir haben von 50
Schülern waren wir glaube ich 23 Mädchen
dabei
wir unterscheiden da nicht also es kommt
wirklich da auf die Leistungsfähigkeit
darauf an die sich präsentiert bei der
Aufnahme ob dann Bub oder Mädchen ist
gleich so die sind
stehenabilitärisch in einer Reihe sind
vergattet ich darf aber trotzdem mit
ihnen reden ich setze ihr seid nicht im
halb acht ja darf ich mit dir anfangen
du bist Christoph Löw und du bist in
welchem Jahrgang im zweiten Jahr das
heißt du hast schon ein Jahr hinter dir
bis jetzt im zweiten hast schon ein
bisschen Erfahrung wie gefällt es dir
eigentlich relativ gut eigentlich das
ist so ein bisschen ja was könnte denn
noch besser werden
naja es gibt halt immer wieder Zeiten
die sehr fordern aber im Nachhinein
denkt man sich schon dass es eine geile
Zeit war dann geile Zeit gefällt mir und
ja
was sind so deine Lieben segenstände in
der Schule also ganz vorne an mit der
die aus der Schule Ausbildung und dann
kommst du Sachen wie wahlsport aber auch
Sicherheitsmanagement gefällt mir auch
sehr gut und wie bist du zu dieser
Schuldige kommen hast du da im Internet
gelesen haben dich deine Eltern darauf
aufmerksam gemacht wie ist das bei Dir
gewesen meine Eltern wussten gar nicht
von der Schule ich habe sie übers
Internet erfahren weil es mich sehr
interessiert hat habe mir dann die
Schule angeschaut und bin zum Schluss
gekommen dass ich mich da anmelden
möchte sehr gut
ich gehe jetzt gleich weiter zur der
damit wir haben gesehen du bist
ein die Repräsentantin für fast die
Hälfte der Schüler
wie heißt du denn
und du wissen welchen Jahrgang
also hast schon zwei Jahre absolviert
also ich bin in der ersten Klasse
aber halt also
und wie gefällt es dir
und wie bist du auf diese Schule
gekommen
ähm also ich habe mich schon immer fürs
Bundeswehr interessiert und meine
Familie ist auch vom Bundeswehr und dann
habe ich mir dann gedacht ja es muss
doch eine Schule so gegeben und dann
mache ich so mache ich hier ganz
plötzlich okay ich danke dir wir sind
jetzt mit diesem Zeitfenster vorbei ich
danke und
wir übergeben wieder
um was zu tun
der Herr Bundespräsident und danach die
Bundesregierung gedenken heute am 26
Oktober der Unterzeichnung des
neutralitätsgesetzes setzen hiermit
einen Staatsakt und
im weiraum wird eine ganzniederlegung
und Anwesenheit einer ehrenkomponie der
Garde stattfinden warum
ist das weil das Äußere Burgtor seit
sehr langer Zeit ein Symbol für die
Republik und das wiederlangen der
Selbstständigkeit in Österreich ist es
ist aber auch das Ehrenmal der Republik
Österreich überhaupt was ist denn die
Rolle des Bundespräsidenten an diesem
Nationalfeiertag erst der
Oberbefehlshaber des österreichischen
Bundesheeres und somit obliegt es auch
ihm diesen Kranz entsprechend
niederzulegen mit militärischen Ehren
und
er ist als höchster Vertreter der
Republik logischerweise das
Aushängeschild der diesen Staatsakt das
richtige Gesicht gibt ganz konkret was
erwartet uns denn jetzt am Heldenplatz
in der kommenden Stunde wenn jetzt in
der Herr Bundespräsident dann beim
heldentor an eintrifft eine
ehrenkomponie sehen die besteht aus dem
kompaniekommandanten aus einem
insignientrupp der Musik und einer gare
Kompanie sowie Soldaten die den Kanzler
niederlegen werden
das ganze ist protokollarisch sehr fix
und fest geregelt vom Ablauf her auch
das werden wir gut beobachten können und
der Höhepunkt ist dann im Endeffekt das
Niederlegen des Kranzes und das Richten
der Schleife im Raum
ja die ganzen
ung wird teuer stattfinden das Äußere
Burgtor grenzt den Heldenplatz zur
Ringstraße ab also je nachdem wo man
steht sieht man mehr oder weniger gut
dass naturs und das Kunsthistorische
Museum und die frühere Winterreitschule
heute das Museumsquartier das Burgtor
war immer eine Stätte des Gedenkens für
gefallene Soldaten Klaus bruckmannhand
Klaus Bruckmann hat jetzt die
wichtigsten historischen Details für Sie
[Musik]
Kranzniederlegungen in der Krypta des
äußeren burgtoris sind ein fixer
Bestandteil der alljährlichen Feiern zum
Nationalfeiertag solche Ereignisse
laufen seit Jahrzehnten nach demselben
Protokoll ab seit dem Vorjahr auch mit
Masken
das Burgtor oder heldentor wurde unter
Kaiser Franz dem ersten von Soldaten der
Armee errichtet unter anderem wurde
Stein aus Kaisersteinbruch verwendet
in der Zwischenkriegszeit wurde das
Äußere Burgtor zu einem Helden Denkmal
umgebaut der Ständestaat wollte an die
Gefallenen des Ersten Weltkriegs
erinnern dazu wurde von der Hofburg aus
gesehen rechts eine Krypta errichtet mit
einem kinotarf eines toten Soldaten aus
roten Marmor hier wurde bis vor wenigen
Jahren jeden Sonntag eine katholische
Messe gefeiert
auf der linken Seite wurde 1965 ein
weihraum eingerichtet mit einem
schwarzen Marmorblock für die Opfer des
österreichischen Freiheitskampfes
seit der Erlangung der Unabhängigkeit
Österreichs 1955 sind
kleinstniederlegungen ein fixer
Bestandteil des Gedenkens
[Musik]
was passiert hier was sehen wir hier
also wir sehen jetzt den Herrn Bundes-
das ankündigungssignal des Trompeters
soll die Truppe darüber informieren dass
der höchstanwesende jetzt anwesend ist
und wir werden nun
die Meldung des Ehrenkompanie an den
Herrn Bundespräsidenten sehen
was hat es damit der Meldung auf sich
was ist das für eine Meldung er meldet
dem Herrn Bundespräsident die
Angestellte eine Gruppe zum Festtag dass
sie quasi bereitstehen
jede Musik der Garde gut zu erkennen und
den roten
der
militärmusikchef das österreichischen
Bundesheeres hier gerade im Bild
obersteher
ein Bundespräsidenten jetzt gemeldet und
nun
wird die Front abgeschritten am Weg zum
Währung
[Musik]
was ist der protokollarisch alles
vorgesehen
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt hier die Geistlichkeit
die ebenfalls anwesend ist so wie Gäste
aus Polizei und Militär
und nun weil es nachdem sich der
Kompaniekommandant abgemeldet hat geht
der Herr Bundespräsident in den weihraum
dort sehen Sie jetzt den Kranz der
Republik
der unter dem Kommando eines
Unteroffiziers hier jetzt wieder gelegt
wird die beiden Soldaten die jetzt
gerade im Bild sind das sind
Grundwehrdiener der
das einrückungstermins
und schaltet
der Bundespräsident gemeinsam mit der
Frau
Bundesministerin zum zum Kranz und
richtet symbolisch die Schleife und wir
hören dann einen Koran
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das
erbitten weiterer Befehle ja
Ehren company Komments wieder
präsentiert recht schaut das heißt
erntezeugung der ehrenkomponie an den
Herrn Bundespräsidenten und erbittet
weitere Befehle
ja wir sind hier wieder bei unseren
route-simulatoren und was wir Ihnen
jetzt bieten ist eine richtige Challenge
einen Wettbewerb zwischen einem Profi
und einem
leoprofi ja schauen wir mal schauen wir
mal ja aber um das Pferd zu machen es
geht um 200 Meter die sie jetzt am
Simulator bewegen müssen aber weil du
ein neoprofi bist
50 Meter Vorsprung ja und die Wiki macht
Schiedsrichterin du gibst auch Kommando
oder
okay das passt
dann Wiki
hat 20 Schüler von der Schule liegt da
ordentlich los
und
Mandy los auf geht's hier
[Musik]
[ __ ] ausgab dass ich nichts so wird das
angeht
der Tennis sind noch vorne
Wahnsinn Wahnsinn
jetzt nicht mehr oder doch
[Applaus]
aber man sieht den mehrfachen Welt und
Europameister und paralympics
aber tapfer geschlagen muss ich schon
sagen Stopp Stopp Stopp fertig so
motiviert 200 Meter in 1 27 wenn ich das
jetzt richtig Entschuldigung in 35
Sekunden wenn ich das jetzt richtig lese
ja und ein 27 sind
und wie geht's dir
gute Leistung
hatte der alles abverlangt schon ja
und
jetzt hat den Geschmack gekommen
ja war schon anstrengend
naja okay also wie schaut's aus mit die
näher Profi werden wir dich eben
[Musik]
vielleicht in dieser Sportart auch
erleben
aber es ist ein Interesse jetzt mal da
ich scheint sehr interessant und eine
gute Karriere ist auch möglich glaube
ich in dieser Disziplin okay das nenne
ich Optimismus und positive
Lebenseinstellung
also
war gar nicht so locker oder na also
die 35 Sekunden also von sowas kann ich
im echten Leben nur träumen am ergo
geht's aber
ich bin Leistungssportler also halbe
Sachen gibt es nicht und vor allem hat
man gesehen dass du doch von der
Frequenz auch hochgelegt hast ist das
vergleichbar mit der wettkampffrequenz
oder muss das dann langsam angehen von
der bewegungsschnelligkeit nach
definitiv also der Ergo sagt 145 das
kommt sicher mal hin also ich habe ihn
Widerstand relativ gering gewählt darum
war die Frequenz vielleicht extra hoch
aber
also 145 ist sicher im Bereich vom
Wettkampf im noch der Faktor hinzu dass
du das Boot ja auch noch ausbalancieren
muss wie viel leichter ist es Ergometer
als im Boot selbst
also ich fühle mich ein Boot wohler
besonders durch den Faktor halt noch
dass das Boot wackelt aber
natürlich manche Leute tun sich am ergo
leichter und es ist dann immer so diese
wie berechnet sich die Distanz und so
weiter also
im Boot ist einfach gescheiter weil da
macht die Physik für dich alle
Berechnungen da musst du nicht
nachdenken wie ist die Formel im
Hintergrund die läuft beim ergo und
jeder hat die gleichen Bedingungen und
wenn ein mehrfacher Welt und Obermeister
und Paralympics Medaillengewinner so ins
Schnaufen kommt dann war das auf jeden
Fall nicht locker also danke Mandy und
danke Dennis ja wirklich was mich
interessieren wird
dass dieser Sport ist ja jetzt nicht so
dieser populäre Sport wir wie kommt man
zu diesen Sports ich habe gar keine
andere Wahl gehabt weil meine Eltern
haben spare gemacht dann ist es in die
Wiege gelegt worden
und ja also ich glaube viele fangen
durch Familienmitglieder an in
Österreich
in anderen Nationen ist es sehr wohl
sehr populärer Sport aber ja ich doch
durch meine Eltern okay aber die haben
dich nicht gezogen sondern schon
freiwillig na um Gottes Willen ich habe
viel ausprobieren dürfen ich habe eine
Ballettkarriere hinter mir dann habe ich
zum Handballspiel angefangen habe meine
Grazie von Ballett wieder verloren und
schlussendlich bin ich dann beim
kalkspsport blieben und da fühlst du
dich zu Hause definitiv ja und da werden
wir auch viel erleben von dir
okay wie bist du eigentlich zum
tadelsport gekommen also bei mir war das
Zufall mit sieben Jahren habe ich meine
Beine verloren und wir waren immer eine
wassersportfreudige Familie aber dann
hat unser Bekannter ein Kajak gegeben
der sie ausprobieren habe können durch
unsere Verbindung zum Wassersport war
heute unterwegs und dann sind die
Mitglieder meine jetzigen Vereins bei
einer Wanderfahrt vorbeigekommen haben
mich paddeln gesehen und haben gefragt
hey willst du nicht an meinem Verein das
machen und der Rest ist Geschichte ich
darf nur sagen er schnauft noch immer
also du hast ihn gefordert
du bist wir haben es gar kein Handicap
gegeben also
natürlich hätte ihn auch gewinnen lassen
können und jetzt weniger schnaufen aber
wie gesagt als Leistungssportler
fällt er seinen schwer andere
vorzulassen
aber du hast die gefordert das erst nach
wie vor
in der Regenerationsphase ich bin auch
seit dem Spielen und nicht so richtig
wieder ins Training eingestiegen okay
also
trainingspart aber ist ja auch nicht im
Training gewesen aber es war ein toller
Wettkampf ja das heißt du hast jetzt am
Wasser mehr oder weniger ist das ist
eine Leidenschaft genau also
verbringen viel also neben dem
Kajakfahren auch sehr viel Zeit so im
Kajak gerade letzte Woche bin ich von
Wien nach Budapest gepaddelt mit dem
Kanu das ist so ganz schöne Strecke ja
also heutzutage geht man halt gerne in
die Natur aber mit meine Beine komme ich
nicht so leicht auf einem Berg jetzt
gehe einfach gern einfach so mit dem
Kajak längere Touren also letztes Jahr
war von Ulm nach Linz dieses Jahr von
Wien nach Budapest also ist dann 340
waren es dieses Jahr letztes Jahr waren
es 440 bin gespannt was ich nächstes
Jahr mache und irgendwann bis zum
Schwarzen Meer dann hoffentlich oder
irgendwann einmal über den Atlantik wow
das sind Pläne das sind Pläne also da
bin ich mir der viel viel Spaß viel
Glück ahoi haben wir das schon fast
sagen Strom auf Strom auf wieder was
gelernt ja
[Musik]
vielleicht ein Zeichen von der Regie wie
viel Zeit wir noch haben für diesen
Einstieg
sonst schlage ich vor dass wir wieder
uns in eine Pause das fällt jetzt wird
langsam warm eigentlich
und der Dennis
schnauft nicht einmal mehr das heißt für
ihn war das wirklich auch entspannt geht
er könnte nächsten Wettkampf machen wir
gleich gegen mich vielleicht einarmig
dann und wir haben auf jeden Fall was
gesehen und absolut auf jeden Fall Kajak
für jeden möglich wenn man sich hier
begeistern hat lassen ja dann gehen wir
zurück an die Regie danke sehr
Zwischenlandung in der
franz-wieten-kaserne in Wien
Stammersdorf die Augusta Bell 212 ist in
der Früh aus Linz Herrsching angeflogen
24 Stück des leichten Transport
Hubschraubers stehen seit 1980 im Besitz
der Republik in den gut 40 Jahren war
die Maschine ein verlässliches Fluggerät
für das Bundesheer bei sämtlichen In-
und Auslandseinsätzen bevor die
dreiköpfige Crew wieder abhebt führt die
Copilotin einen neuerlichen staatscheck
durch in der Zwischenzeit ist die um
einiges größere Black Hawk der schwarze
Falke gelandet
ready for Tick off die akkustabel 212
macht sich auf den Weg Richtung Wiener
Innenstadt bei besten Bedingungen
wolkenloser Himmel Fernsicht wie aus dem
Bilderbuch
[Musik]
im parallelflug steuern die beiden
Hubschraubern nebeneinander 300 Meter
über Wien der Blick aus dem Cockpit ist
auch für die heerespiloten ein ganz
besonderer die Überstellung muss der
extra genehmigt werden über Wien besteht
auch für Bundeswehr Maschinen striktes
Flugverbot nach knapp 10 minütiger
Flugzeit ist das Ziel der Heldenplatz
erreicht
putzende Schaulustige nehmen den Black
Hawk in Empfang die Landung wie auf
Wolken trotz der nicht ganz so einfachen
Bedingungen heute ja wir haben heute ist
einiges Wetter Glück gehabt das war zwar
etwas windig und doch turbulent der
Heldenplatz selbst ist aufgrund der
Gegebenheiten mit Hindernissen die da
sind doch eng das heißt es müssen halt
alle Crewmitglieder genau aufpassen
rausschauen aber natürlich ist es doch
Routine landen der flugtechniker der
Augusta Bell 212 bringt die Maschine vor
der Nationalbibliothek in Parkposition
dafür werden blattfesseln angebracht die
Rotorblätter am Boden fixiert Teile des
Black Hawk werden abgedeckt um
Beschädigungen von oben zu verhindern
auch wenn niemand zu den Maschinen darf
und der Heldenplatz heute gesperrt ist
dank virtueller 3D Technik gibt es eben
online die Möglichkeit im Black Hawk
Platz zu nehmen ganz ohne anstellen
[Musik]
wie aufwendig ist denn diese ganze
militärische Besiedlung eigentlich an
diesem Nationalfeiertag es ist schon ein
ein
großes Thema für vor allem das
Militärkommando Wien dass da die
Federführung in der in den Details zu
Durchführungen in den Details zu
Durchführung hat und im Endeffekt
beginnt der Nationalfeiertag des
nächsten Jahres morgen mit der
Auswertung genau mit der Auswertung
dessen was ist gut gegangen was war
nicht so gut also letztens lernt
letztens seit Endeffekt werden dann
eingebracht und wo es dann wirklich
losgeht ist dann der Frühjahr nächsten
Jahres geht man dann in die Planung dann
wird man sehen wie das wie ist die
Situation geht dann wieder zu einer
größeren
Leistungsshow über wie wir sie ja die
letzten Jahre hatten oder sind wir
Corona bedingt was ich nicht hoffe
wieder in einem eingeschränkten Rahmen
unterwegs es ist ja vielleicht gar nicht
uninteressant dass er hier eines ein
sehr enges Zusammenwirken nicht nur
zwischen dem Militär und der Stadt Wien
passiert sondern das auch mit der mit
der Burghauptmannschaft dem wir haben
für sich dort diese Grundstücke ablegen
bzw zum Beispiel der Rasen wenn er
kaputt gemacht wird der durch die durch
die
Bundesforste wieder
hergestellt werden muss und das letzte
ist dann im Endeffekt das Heranführen
das Gerät wie man gesehen haben der
Hubschrauber das ist natürlich sehr
aufwendig oder wenn wir große gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge nach Wien hereinbringen das
ist etwas aufwendiger ist aber dann im
Endeffekt nur mehr der Grünen der
Abschluss der Vorbereitung Pannen
gesprochen
aber was gibt es denn dafür Pannen zum
Beispiel die man sich dann merkt für das
nächste Jahr
es kann immer wieder zu Pannen kommen
also mir persönlich ist jetzt nichts
so bekannt nachdem wir eine so im Inside
der Veranstaltung dort bin was ich jetzt
erzählen könnte aber es geht natürlich
oft auch um Kleinigkeiten um Abläufe ob
die richtigen Leute zu richtigen Zeit um
richtigen Ort sind das dann immer wieder
Dinge die Vorkommen wir sind ja alle nur
Menschen noch mal vielleicht zu Corona
wie wie sehr hat wirklich Corona das
ganze sehr schwer diese militärische
Besiedelung da am Nationalfeiertag mit
dem mit den Geräten wenn wir uns
zurückerinnen voriges Jahr waren wir ja
überhaupt reduziert auf 12
Grundwehrdiener die angelobt worden sind
heuer sind zumindest hundert und es ist
auch möglich angeht die Angehörigen
einzuladen was er aus meiner Sicht der
ganze wichtiges Thema ist sonst haben
wir in der großhandelobung um die 1000
und ein bisschen mehr Soldaten das ist
dann natürlich schon eine ganze
viel größerer Aufwand
aber ich denke dass mittlerweile das
Militär und auch die ganze Republik
schon relativ gut mit der
corona-situation hat gelernt umzugehen
und somit Abstandsregeln und die Masken
durchaus kein Thema mehr sind ich höre
gerade die Regierung macht sich schon
auf den Weg vom Ballhausplatz über die
Kastanienallee auch zum äußeren
Burgtor und wir schalten zu Saskia
venenboss am Ballhausplatz
ja es kann sich nur noch um Sekunden
haben bis die gesamte Bundesregierung
nach dem Ministerrat alle Minister hier
den Weg durch die Kastanienallee
Antreten zur grenzenderlegung
Hans Bürger wir sehen
Alexander Schallenberg den Bundeskanzler
wer ist denn da noch alles dabei
drehen
[Musik]
ich nehme schon an dass die gesamte
Bundesregierung da ist neben
den Bundeskanzler sehe ich den
Vizekanzler auch die
Verteidigungsministerin ist da
Ministerin Köstinger
Raab Kocher
also bis jetzt
nicht sehen würde das war letztes Jahr
auch deutlich dezimiert die Regierung
kommt von einem Ministerrat was ist da
heute besprochen worden bei Ministerrat
es ist beschlossen wann das
krisensicherungsgesetz wo
wir gestern auch schon in der Zeit im
Bild berichtet haben und wenn die
genaueren Details bei sicher daher
general major grundsätzlich geht es
darum dass wir eine krisenkoordinator
bekommen einen der regierungskoordinaten
für Krisensituationen wo es möglich ist
bis zu drei Krisen gleichzeitig zu
handeln also wie das genau funktionieren
soll weiß ich natürlich nicht da weiß
ich der Experte mehr aber es ist ja so
und ich habe es jetzt in meiner in
meiner Wortmeldung auch gesagt wir
kommen davon einer Krise in die andere
und man stelle sich vor es kommen
mehrere Krisen zusammen denken wir an
den November vor ziemlich genau einem
Jahr als es zu diesem fürchterlichen
Attentat in Wien gekommen ist dann gibt
es auf der anderen Seite immer wieder
etwas dass man nicht aussprechen darf
weil sehr viele Leute sagen wir sind
alle Panik verbreitert aber es ist nun
mal ein Thema wir sprechen von diesem
Blackout keine Ahnung wie groß diese
Gefahr wirklich ist sie wird immer
wieder thematisiert dann gibt es
natürlich Umweltkatastrophen jetzt
stelle man sich vor alle drei Krisen
fallen zusammen
es ist interessant dass man sich sogar
offenbar auf so ein Szenario vorbereitet
und es dürfte aber dieses Gesetz schon
relativ konsensual am Ende beschlossen
worden sein denn wieder zur Erinnerung
wir haben es ja eigentlich hier nicht
mit zwei Parteien zu tun die sich
ideologisch nahe stehen ganz im
Gegenteil wir haben ja gehört am Anfang
es gibt eine Regierung wo beide das
Beste aus ihrer Welt zusammenfügen
wollen hat das Beste aus ihrer Welt ist
wenn wir von den Grünen sprechen sicher
nicht die
sicherheitstangente die große Frage das
Sicherheit ist eher typisch ÖVP und eher
typisch freiheitliches da hätten sie
sich sicher bei den Verhandlungen
leichter gedankt die letzte Regierung
türkisblau aber auch diese Regierung hat
das zusammengebracht beide loben jetzt
dieses Gesetz aber wenn man sich die
Worte von Vizekanzler Kogler und
grünenchef Kogler und auch von
Innenminister nehammer anhört da findet
man jetzt eigentlich kaum irgendein
Blatt Papier dazwischen also so gesehen
glaube ich eher ein großer Wurf ja
der generalma ja was ist denn da jetzt
protokollarisch eigentlich anders als
bei der Kranzniederlegung mit dem Herrn
Bundespräsidenten
zum Beispiel ein anderes Trompetensignal
in der Ankündigung zusteht das ist ein
wesentlicher Unterschied und das an und
für sich der der
ehrenkompaniekommandant bei der
Abmeldung sich einfach abmeldet und
keine weiteren Befehle
erbittet weil ja der Bundeskanzler nicht
in der Führung des Bundesheeres
involviert ist also er ist nicht in der
in der befehlshirearchie das ist nur
jetzt ein kleines Beispiel ja aber das
ist zum Beispiel ein anderen Ländern
anders in Deutschland zum Beispiel ist
er glaube ich der Bundeskanzler der
Oberbefehlshaber ist das korrekt das ist
korrekt ja das ist bei uns anders
geregelt das haben wir verfassungsmäßig
mit dem Bundespräsidenten und die
Verfügungsgewalt über das Bundesheer
obliegt der Verteidigungsministerin
warum ist das bei uns so geregelt
ich denke dass das aus der kelsenschen
Verfassung her sehr gut geregelt ist und
aus dem auch ein bisschen aus dem
Zeitgeist heraus entstanden ist wir
hören wieder ist dass das ankündigungs-
die Blicke das ist ja auch alles streng
protokollarisch geregelt
auch wird das natürlich eingehend
vorgeübt viele viele Stunden in der
Maria Theresien Kaserne Vertrieb
verbringen die Garde Soldaten damit
hier dann richtig einen scharfen Einsatz
durchzuführen
gerade Offiziere mit der goldenen Schnur
die unteroffizielle meine silbernen
und heuer ohne Maske letztes Jahr mit
Maske
[Musik]
es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche
barrettfarben was hat es damit auf sich
oder sollen wir jetzt eher lauschen
[Musik]
nun setzen sich deren Gäste in Marsch
der Bundeskanzler ganz innen sie haben
gesendetchef hat jetzt die Seite
gewechselt dass der Rang höchste neben
der Information
entlang geht
der Rest der Bundesregierung verbleibt
hinten
weil sie vorher gefragt haben wegen dem
Unterschied deutlich zu sehen die Fahne
hier erhoben beim Bundespräsidenten war
sie gesenkt das ist eben etwas was man
den Staatsoberhaupt und zusteht
[Musik]
die Soldaten verfolgen jetzt den
höchstens in dem Fall der Bundeskanzler
auf seinem Weg
die Blicke
jetzt auch der Gang in den weihraum also
vorher gefragt haben wegen das wegen des
roten Paretz das ist der scharlachrote
Barrett dass die Garde trägt das hängt
mit den Aufschlag und waffenfarben des
Bundesheeres zusammen die bandzuleiten
zum Beispiel ein schwarzes Brett die
Jäger ein grünes so kann man die
Soldaten noch ihre waffengarten nach
unterscheiden
oder der Kranz abgelegt
und jetzt kommt wieder das symbolische
richten
[Musik]
wieder auf präsentiert recht schaut
hergestellt wieder der Blick auf den
höchsten Anwesenden und der
Ehrenkompanie kommen dann
[Musik]
die Frequenz abmelden
vorstellen das ist schon eine
Sondersituation für einen Garde Kompanie
Kommandanten diese ist diese Fertigkeit
um 26 oktober gibt es selbst wiederholt
durchgeführt meistens schon selbst auch
ein bisschen aufgeregt
ja also wir haben jetzt die Regierung
gesehen die ist jetzt wieder am Rückweg
es kommen dann zumindest Bundeskanzler
Schallenberg und die
Verteidigungsministerin Tana wieder
zurück für die Reden auf der papstbühne
was machen die jetzt in der Zwischenzeit
gehen die jetzt einen Kaffee trinken
oder es ist ein so ein Zelt aufgebaut in
dem die Ehrengäste gut untergebracht
werden die verbundenheitsminister trifft
sich ja jetzt unmittelbar im Anschluss
noch zu einer kanzlerlegung mit den
Opferverbänden am im weiraum und sie
sehen
man massiert jetzt gemeinsam in das dort
aufgebrachte große Zelt und überbrückt
quasi die Zeit bis zur Angelobung
Hans Bürger die Regierung eben am
Rückweg im Bundeskanzler Scharnberg ist
der erst seit zwei Wochen im Amt er wird
danach eine Rede halten was kann man
sich denn von dieser Rede erwarten
ich glaube er wird eine Rede halten die
sich deutlich von der unterscheiden wird
dir am Beginn seiner Amtszeit gehalten
wird die ja zum Teil sehr umstritten war
wo er eigentlich
sehr stark darauf eingegangen ist wie
sein Verhältnis zum bisherigen
Bundeskanzler und Parteichef der ÖVP
Sebastian Kurz ist da ist der schwer
kritisiert worden weil gesagt worden ist
er müsste sich in seiner ersten Rede als
Bundeskanzler eigentlich über die Partei
stellen und sollte nicht jetzt Bezug
nehmen auf die
schwierige Situation innerhalb der ÖVP
die sich durch die chat-affäre da
ergeben hat auf der anderen Seite werden
jene die glauben dass es als eine
Vermutung von mir dass er sich dass er
diese Loyalität infrage stellt sich
vermutlich auch täuschen denn
Schallenberg wird den Weg gemeinsam mit
Sebastian Kurz gehen was die Parteilinie
betrifft wird sich aber als
Bundeskanzler in seinen Reden davon ab
müssen sonst wird es immer wieder heißen
wie es in den Medien ja schon geheißen
hat dass Sebastian Kurz der Schatz
schattenkanzler bleibt so gesehen
erwarte ich heute eine sehr
staatsministische Rede eine Rede in der
er möglicherweise gar nicht auf die
Situation in der eigenen Partei eingeht
eine Rede in ihrer auf die Zukunft
Österreichs eingeht und ich halte das
auch für sehr notwendig denn wir sind
nach wie vor in einer corona-krise die
leider wieder größer geworden ist wir
sind in einer Krise wo wir darüber
nachdenken müssen wie werden wir die
Wirtschaftslage Österreich stabilisieren
und wir werden wir auch die politische
Lage stabilisieren und deshalb erwarte
ich mir heute eine dem Anlass
entsprechende Rede sie haben gesagt wir
sind in einer corona-krise nach wie vor
aber sind wir auch nach wie vor in einer
Regierungskrise nämlich auch mit dem
Neuwahl Gespenst dass da immer wieder
herumgeistert auch
das hängt ganz davon ab wie sich
das muss man eigentlich eigentlich wie
sich die drei nicht wollte ich sagen
zwei aber es hängt es sind ja drei es
müssen sich der Vizekanzler und Grünen
Chef werden nach Kogler der
Bundeskanzler Schallenberg unter
Parteichef kurz auf einen Weg einigen
mit dem alle drei leben können und der
dann auch in der Basis bei der Parteien
akzeptiert wird also wenn es so ist dass
es Spannungen gäbe zwischen Kogler und
kurz dann nützt es nichts das
schalenberg Kanzler ist aber man hat
gehört dass es schon am vergangenen
Freitag ein längeres Gespräch zwischen
dem grünen Chef und dem ÖVP-Chef gegeben
haben soll dass der konstruktiv
verlaufen ist wobei ich solche
Schlussfolgerungen immer sehr
interessant und fast lustig empfinden
aber es werden Sie sagen nach einer nein
es war nicht konstruktiv und wir haben
drei Stunden gestritten also wir werden
es nie erfahren dass die beiden unter
vier Augen wirklich gesprochen haben
aber immerhin sie haben beide von einem
konstruktiven Gespräch gesprochen und
deshalb wiederhole ich wenn diese Achse
hält diese dreiachse dann glaube ich
kann es längere Zeit halten wenn diese
Achse ein wenig ins Schwanken gerät das
kurz von scharlberg Dinge will die der
nicht will und umgekehrt da muss ich
sagen gehört ja gehöre ich auch zu Ihnen
die ihr mit Neuwahlen 2022 rechnen
was glauben Sie denn wird
Bundespräsident Alexander van der Bellen
in seiner Rede auch noch auf die
Regierungskrise eingehen oder wird das
dann schon gesagt die regierungsgröße
ist eigentlich vorbei
also die Rede die wir heute auch live in
ORF 2 sehen werden wo auch schon erste
Ausschnitte aus dieser Rede in der Zeit
im Bild eins zeigen können
soweit sie mir bekannt ist und ein
bisschen was habe ich schon gehört wird
sie sich überraschenderweise dem
Schwerpunkt klimawidmen der
Bundespräsident will jetzt glaube ich
heraus aus der corona-thematik und will
sich diesem Hauptthema das ist ja
gegeben hätte wäre Corona nicht gekommen
extrem widmen er hat da sich sehr viel
in den letzten Wochen auch besprochen
mit Experten und das ist ihm ein extrem
wichtiges Thema und das zweite was ich
höre die zweite Säule dieser Rede soll
sich mit der Spaltung der Gesellschaft
befassen und da muss ich sagen das ist
auch gut so dass er sich damit befasst
denn eigentlich leben wir mit Corona in
einer noch größeren Spaltung aus meiner
Sicht als in der Flüchtling Ende 2015
vielen Dank Hans Bürger fürs Erste und
jetzt kommen wir wieder zu den
Olympioniken die am Heldenplatz noch
immer fleißig am Morgensport sind fast
gewinnen Boss ist für uns gemeinsam mit
Philipp Jelinek vor Ort mitten im
Geschehen was wird denn da gerade geübt
Saskia
ja körperliche Fitness sie ist ja ein
wesentlicher Bestandteil um
militärischer Aufträge zu erfüllen und
deswegen prüft unser Fortuna Philipp
Jelinek hier die Olympia Teilnehmer auf
ihre sportlichen Leistungen fordert sie
ganz schön heraus
richtig schöne große Bewegungen sind wir
drinnen sieht man ganz kurz aus jetzt
versuchen wir einen Achter einen
stehenden Achter zu zeichnen und
versuchen dabei auch so ein bisschen in
die Knie zu gehen genau ja meine Damen
und Herren zu Hause die die Lust und
Laune haben ihr könnt gerne mal
aufstehen ebenfalls probieren hier ein
bisschen mitzumachen Bewegung ist Leben
vor allem regelmäßige Bewegung und wenn
wir jetzt einmal unten sind Wechsel man
mal die Richtung ja also mit der
Richtungswechsel gehen wir nach unten
wieder schön nach oben genau
das sieht gut aus und das Schöne ist
diese Bewegungen können Alt und Jung
ausüben Einsteiger Fortgeschrittene und
auch Profis sehr schön okay wir
schütteln kurz Auskommen zu Körpermitte
rumstabilität immer so ein Thema dafür
strecken wir die Arme nach oben dann ein
Bein gescheit verwurzeln und jetzt lösen
wir das andere Haus und bewegen uns
einmal zu der einen Seite wir
konzentrieren uns kommen zur Mitte
Standbein andere Seite jawohl und auch
da wieder Konzentration Einsteiger
beginnen hier fortgeschrittene gehen
weiter nach unten Profi soweit es geht
kurz halten wieder retour kommen wenn es
geht dabei Lächeln aufsetzen jawohl
andererseits
und wie gesagt die Regelmäßigkeit bringt
den Erfolg und für alle Damen und Herren
die jetzt zu Hause sitzen und sagen hey
das wäre doch was cooles Montag bis
Freitag findet Philipp immer nach der
neuen Uhrzeit würde mich freuen wenn ihr
mit dabei seid ja andere Seite wieder
retour einmal geht's noch einmal noch
andere Seite
jawohl sehr schön kommen zur Mitte
nächste Position leichte Grätsche ja wir
gehen mit den Armen nach unten
Bauchnabel zieht nach innen Arme 90 Grad
und jetzt ziehen wir praktisch da nach
oben ja schön nach oben ziehen genau
Einsteiger Variante
sehr gut die Fortgeschrittenen können
versuchen das Ganze einbeinig auszuüben
ja sehr gut und die Profis machen es
einbeinig sie nach oben und dann kommt
aber auch noch genau die Stabilisation
dazu wir kommen retour damit sie nach
unten ja das ist die Profi Variante ja
Einsteiger Beginner ganz ganz locker
ziehen einfach nur die Arme nach oben
und wenn das dann funktioniert einmal
versuchen das Ganze einbeinig zu machen
das heißt nicht nur die Kräftigung haben
wir da Schulter Nackenbereich sondern
auch unser Gleichgewicht wird geschult
und wenn das dann passt versuchen wir
nach oben zu ziehen und dann lang machen
einmal Strecken kurz halten retour
kommen nach unten und natürlich auch der
beinwechsel ist ganz ganz wichtig so
anderes Bein einmal versuchen und nach
oben ziehen
sehr schön
das tut gut ja sehr schön Profi Variante
haben wir gesagt und wir kommen wieder
zur Mitte Schüttung kurz aus
Mobilisation Körpermitte auch ganz
wichtig wir bleiben in der Position
gehen nach unten stützen uns dort ich
stelle mir seitlich hin und jetzt Wirbel
für Wirbel geben wir nach oben Richtung
Katzenbuckel ja und komme wieder nach
unten zurück
ja sehr schön und da wieder nach oben
also wer mobilisieren wir aktivieren wir
machen was koordinatives wir kräftigen
schön langsam von oben nach unten und
wer möchte kann da natürlich jetzt
einmal versuchen ja sein Gesäß von
rechts nach links zu bewegen so richtig
schön
ganz ganz wichtig die meisten sind eh
viel zu steif damit wieder nach oben zu
gehen
ja komm wieder zu euch nach vorne sehr
gut
sehr schön und wieder nach oben
und wieder retour Wirbel für Wirbel ja
sehr gut okay und wir richten uns wieder
auf so jetzt machen wir noch Geschichte
gemeinsam hoppala Mikrofon
und zwar wir stellen uns hin Arme nach
vorne gerade so Position 1 dann Winkeln
wir die Arme an Position zwei gehen nach
außen die Hände hoch Position und werde
manche rüsten ihren Körper auf andere
rüsten sich für ein sogenanntes Blackout
also einem weiträumigen vielleicht sogar
europaweiten
strominfrastruktur oder
versorgungsausfall Handys Internet
Bankomat Tankstellen Tunnel Bahnverkehr
Öffis etc all das funktioniert dann
nicht mehr offenbar ist das ein
realistisches und gleichzeitig
unterschätztes Risiko auf dass sich das
österreichische Bundesheer möglichst gut
vorbereiten will denn mehr als vielen
Menschen bewusst ist unser Leben von
einer intakten Stromversorgung abhängig
sind sie jetzt einen Film das vielfach
preisgekrönten österreichischen
Regisseurs und mallasnik über wichtige
Vorsorge und Schutzmaßnahmen die jeder
Einzelne in seinem privaten Umfeld
treffen sollte
[Musik]
dann habe ich beim Fenster rausgeschaut
und habe gesehen dass draußen alles
dunkel ist
nicht nur bei uns und August das
betrifft alle
zum Glück quasi unser Taschenlampen
liegt und habe es gefunden mit einem
Blackout muss man immer rechnen es ist
immer eine Überraschung und es kann
jederzeit passieren aber wir haben
rechtzeitig begonnen uns darauf
vorzubereiten die
Kommunikationsleitungen funktionieren
auch wenn es keinen Strom gibt wir sind
nie ausgeschaltet unsere Aufgabe ist es
die Führungsfähigkeit der Republik im
Notfall zu unterstützen dabei arbeiten
wir direkt mit dem Bundeskanzleramt dem
Innenministerium und anderen staatlichen
Stellen zusammen
zum Glück sind wir gut vorbereitet gute
Vorbereitung ist in dem Fall alles
als erstes wollte man natürlich die
Informationen hören was ist passiert
zum Glück kann man das kugelrad ist und
so ist es unser Fenster zu Außenwelt
bei einer Ausnahmesituation wie einen
Blackout stößt man sehr schnell an die
Grenzen seiner personellen Ressourcen da
helfen wir als Soldaten aus vor allem
was Sicherheit und
infrastrukturproblemen aber natürlich
auch mit dem Einsatz von Spezialgeräten
zum Beispiel mit einem Dieselgenerator
eine lebenswichtige Einrichtung der das
notstromaggrad ausgefallen ist
Lebensmittel für mindestens zwei Wochen
sollte man zu Hause haben vor allem lang
haltbare Lebensmittel
Mittel Reis Getreide Vollkornbrot Wasser
nicht vergessen
Trockenmilch zwei Wochen sollte man
schon zu Hause
die Aufrechterhaltung der Kommunikation
ist ein zentraler Punkt wir bekommen
laufend neue Meldungen die rasch
abgearbeitet und spezialisierten
Einheiten zugewiesen werden
in der Strom ausfällt ist sofort die
Versorgung mit Treibstoff und Wasser
unterbrochen
darauf sind wir vorbereitet und können
Polizei Feuerwehr und Rettung
einsatzfähig halten das macht mich schon
stolz
bei uns war schnell alles wieder normal
zur Abwechslung spielen wir auch mal von
meinem ärgere dich nicht
für so einen Ernstfall sind wir
ausgebildet worden nur dadurch können
wir solche unberechenbaren Situationen
gut meistern
Zeit für Fehler gibt es jetzt nicht
[Musik]
ohne Strom können wichtige Tiefkühllager
ausfallen in diesen Fällen kannst du zu
kommen dass gefährliche Stoffe austreten
bei solchen Einsätzen stehen wir den
Kameraden der Feuerwehr bei
einem Blackout fallen natürlich extrem
viele Versorgungseinrichtungen aus das
betrifft neben dem gesamten
Lebensmittelhandel Tankstelle und
Geschäften auch die Banken wir stehen
bereit mit größeren mannstärken rasch
die Polizei beim Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur zu unterstützen
und dann war wieder Licht
und wir haben es überstanden
ein Film des österreichischen
regisseursnik war das der übrigens auch
geschieht geführt hat bei Filmen die
schnelle mittelt kopfstories oder
großstadtreviert Herr generalm die Frage
ist ja nicht ob ein Blackout passiert
sondern wann ist das korrekt
in unserer
Risikoeinschätzung ist das Blackout
durchaus eines der ernstzunehmenden
Risken das auf uns zukommt beim bei
einem Blackout sprechen wir nicht von
einem
Stromausfall in einem Wiener Bezirk oder
in einem österreichischen Bundesland
sondern wir reden von Teilen ganz
Mitteleuropas oder ganz besser Europas
die hier ohne Strom sind und das dann
über längere Zeit weil das Stromnetz
nicht mehr gemeinsam hochfahren kann das
dauert eine gewisse Zeit die
Herausforderung die wir sehen ist dass
dann die Bevölkerung selbst auf das auf
diese Ausnahmesituation vorbereitet sein
sollte weil im Endeffekt kaum mehr etwas
von dem was wir im täglichen Leben
gewohnt sind sei es jetzt Kommunikation
das heißt dass der E-Herd funktioniert
die Klimaanlage das das ist dann alles
aus aber es geht auch noch weiter es
geht zum Bankenwesen es geht zum
Supermarkt zur Tankstelle das heißt
außer natürlich in die
Sanitätsversorgung
dass gewisse Zeiten sicher mit Notstrom
überbrückt werden können aber irgendwann
die Dieseltanks auch leer sind und wenn
es dann einmal drei vier fünf Tage
dauert dann wird das schon eine sehr
angespannte Situation und somit auch
immer eine Farbe für die
Sicherheitsbehörden das Bundesheer ist
hier in diesem Fall keine
erstreaktionskraft das ist ganz klar bei
der Polizei bei der Feuerwehr auch der
Zivilschutz hat ja einen entsprechende
Rolle aber was wir im Endeffekt zur
Verfügung stellen können ist erstens
einmal ein Backup für
die anderen
[Musik]
Blaulichtorganisationen dass sie zum
Beispiel bei uns im Film auch gezeigt
hat tanken können dass die Polizei
weiterhin auf Streife fahren kann oder
dass wir logischerweise wir bewachen wir
unsere Kasernen ein größeres Areal zur
Verfügung haben wo andere unter
Umständen auch einen sicheren Ort finden
können vielleicht was wie kann sich
jeder einzeln wirklich ganz konkret
darauf vorbereiten für jeden Einzelnen
ist
ganz wesentliches wesentlicher Punkt
schauen wir mal dass man für sieben Tage
oder besser 14 Tage Essen und vor allem
auch Wasser zu Hause haben nämlich
Wasser auch nicht vergessen ganz ganz
wesentlich und wenn wir dann Nudeln Reis
etc einlagern und das hat dann bevor es
zu alt wird dann auch umschlagen dass
man es auch kochen können also wir
sollten vielleicht einen kleinen Kocher
auch zur Verfügung haben
Kerze sein kurbelradio bietet sich an
vielleicht auch ein Erste-Hilfe-Kurs und
was man schon bedenken sollte ist wie
rangiert man das in der Familie wo
trifft man sich weil wir müssen damit
rechnen dass eben die Kommunikation
zuerst überlastet ist dass wir nicht
mehr jeden und überall erreichen können
und das unter Umständen dann die
Kommunikation überhaupt wegbricht das
heißt wo sind meine Kinder wie treffe
ich mich mit meinen Familienmitgliedern
das haben dann schon den Themen mit
denen man sich vorher besser
auseinandersetzt als wenn es soweit ist
also Blackout inszenario mit dem man
sich beschäftigen sollte möglicherweise
ja und wir schalten jetzt zu Saskia
felenboss und einer der Hüterinnen des
österreichischen Luftraums als eine der
wenigen Frauen Saskia wen haben Sie denn
da vor der Kamera
ja ich begrüße hier stabswachtmeister
Nicole m wie sie schon erwähnt haben
Rebecca sie sind also die geheime
Bewacherin des österreichischen
Luftraums quasi und machen das mit
diesem Gerät wir dürfen nicht rein wegen
Geheimhaltungsgründen aber was kann das
denn ja das ist das aufklärungs- und
zielverwaltung mit diesem Gerät fassen
wir und identifizieren wir
luftfahrzeuger und wir dienen dazu dass
wir das
Radarbild der Goldhaube verdichten das
heißt wenn ein Flugobjekt den
österreichischen Luftraum betritt und
keine Genehmigung dafür hat dann sehen
Sie das genau
wo kommt es denn den Einsatz wie oft
machen sie das täglich oder wie oft
kommt denn das vor naja wir kommen im
Einsatz so wie wir angefordert werden
das beste Beispiel ist die
luftraumsicherungsoperation in Davos
also diese Weltwirtschaftsgipfel war
stattfindet dann sind wir jedes Jahr im
Einsatz bei der EU-Präsidentschaft waren
wir auch im Einsatz und wir selber sind
Minimum einmal in der Woche im
radarbetriebsdienst damit wir am Gerät
arbeiten nun dieses Gerät zur
Flugüberwachung das muss ja auch
transportiert werden das ist ein ganz
schön großes Gerät wer Fahrt denn damit
unter anderem fahre ich auch mit dem
Gerät was braucht man dafür einen
Führerschein um so ein riesen Gerät
fahren zu können einen zielführerschein
danke damit wieder zurück zu dir ins
Studio Rebecca vielen Dank Saskia
Einsatz gemeinsam unterwegs mit der
Feuerwehr im Löscheinsatz das sind die
Hubschrauberpiloten des österreichischen
Bundesheeres also die Feuerwehr am Boden
des Bundesheer im Löscheinsatz aus der
Luft bei Naturkatastrophen etwa oder in
Krisenfällen helfen die Kräfte des
Bundesheeres der Bevölkerung und
unterstützen die Einsatzorganisationen
ein Film von Regisseur Harald Staudach
wir üben täglich für den Ernstfall und
sind bereit
grundsätzlich fliegen ist einfach so
unvorstellbar das ist ein Beruf aber
Einstellung die man für Österreich macht
und aus einer persönlichen Überzeugung
die Ausbildung beim Bundesheer ist
ausgezeichnet zum einen weil die
Aufgabenspektrum relativ groß ist dass
wir dann am Einsatz abdecken müssen das
heißt wir müssen aber auch unsere jungen
Piloten dementsprechend in dem gesamten
Einsatzspektrum dann ausbilden und das
haben wir einfach sehr breit gefächert
es macht das ganze Jahr viel viel
interessanter
egal ob Lawinen Waldbrände
Hochwasserkatastrophen ist es natürlich
mit den Hubschrauber sehr nützlich wenn
die Hilfe direkt aus der Luft kommt die
Beweglichkeit der Hubschrauber bietet
und die Einsatzmöglichkeiten sind
einfach ideal
neben der Vorbereitung auf unsere
militärische Aufgabe sind natürlich
jederzeit für die Katastropheneinsätze
verfügbar und jederzeit bereit auch dort
unseren Einsatz zu zeigen
[Musik]
positiv abgeschlossene Einsatz das gibt
einfach selber persönlich gutes Gefühl
Landesverteidigung ist für mich einfach
ein gutes Gefühl für Österreich was tun
zu können
den Land und Luftstreitkräften fügt das
österreichische Bundesheer auch über
Spezialeinsatzkräfte etwa die Soldaten
des Jagdkommandos sie trainieren für
Einsätze unter schwierigsten Gelände und
Witterungsbedingungen und bei extremen
Gefahrensituationen und klimatischen
Bedingungen daher gilt das Jagdkommando
auch als Speerspitze des Bundesheeres
als Mitglied vieler internationaler
Organisationen leistet Österreich seit
über 60 Jahren seinen Beitrag für den
Frieden Soldatinnen und Soldaten des
Bundesheeres haben sich dabei in den
letzten Jahrzehnten einen sehr guten Ruf
erworben Kräfte des Jagdkommandos sind
dabei oft die ersten die in den Einsatz
gehen wenn es um den Schutz unserer
Bevölkerung geht wir sind bereit ob im
Inland oder im Ausland zu Lande zu
Wasser und aus der Luft
Militär war für mich schon immer
aufgrund familiärer Hintergründe das
Größte für mich und somit hat schon
einen Weg gegeben der mich in diesem
Verband geführt hat
eingerückt ef-kurs gemacht und
grundsätzlich einmal die normale
militärische Laufbahn durchgemacht bis
zum Unteroffizier und dann für das
Jagdkommando entschieden
[Musik]
du magst nicht die Ausbildung fertig und
bist dann der überdrüber Soldat sondern
ständiger laufender Prozess sich immer
fortbilden viel zu halten Fähigkeiten
erhalten es dauert bis man wirklich dann
mit sich selbst zufrieden ist
wir sind zum Schutz der Bevölkerung da
ob im Inland oder im Ausland das ist
einer der Kernaufgaben des jackkommandos
die Speerspitze sozusagen das in das
Herz dadurch schützt man halt auch
Österreich
mein Leben ist so sehr Kommando ist auch
an oberster Stelle steht und solange ich
operativ tätig bin ist das der
Lebensmittelpunkt
Hybride Bedrohungen also kombinierte
Bedrohungen etwas klassischen
Militäreinsätzen und Cyberattacken sind
in der heutigen Zeit nichts Neues mehr
da kommt dem abc-schutz von
Einsatzkräften immer mehr Bedeutung zu
die Soldaten der ABC abwehrtruppe sind
für die Abwehr von atomahnbiologischen
und chemischen Gefahren zuständig sie
können gefährliche Stoffe erkennen
Personen und Gerät dekontamieren und
Menschen aus Gefahrenbereichen Bergen
Wachtmeister Florian Bielinski von der
ABC abwehrkommandant-
Umwelt und Naturkatastrophen oder einer
Pandemie wir sind bestmöglich
ausgebildet und ausgerüstet
mein Zwillingsbruder ist vorne
eingerückt als ich dann entschlossen
mein Bundesheer dabei zu bleiben und ich
habe mir gedacht ich möchte zumindestens
im Rang überholen was habe ich dann im
Endeffekt auch geschafft letztes Jahr
ist er nachgezogen ist auch Wachtmeister
geworden
[Musik]
ist eine Materie was sind natürlich sehr
schnell verändert weil immer neue Sachen
dazu kommen es wird einem eigentlich nie
langweilig
dafür ist darum atomare biologische oder
chemische Gefahrstoffe oder Kampfmittel
abwehren zu können beziehungsweise um
sie zu die kontaminieren in Folge
bedeutet dass man eben diesen Raum so
sauber wieder hinbekommt eventuell
normales Leben wieder möglich ist
in Zeiten der Pandemie sind wir auch
eingesetzt worden um Schulen und andere
wichtige Räumlichkeiten wieder so
hinzubekommen dass der normale Betrieb
weitergehen kann ich möchte Menschen
gern helfen und da ist die Arbeit sehr
abwehrkran und für sich einer der
Waffengattungen wo man auch wenn sie mal
wirklich brenzlig wird doch
Einsatzbereiche hat die auch im zivilen
Verwendung finden
und das ist er das Mammut Fahrzeug ein
sogenanntes
dekontaminationsfahrzeug bei mir jetzt
Leutnant Patrick h ein dass die
kontaminationsfahrzeug ist Teil der ABC
abwehrtruppe und wir haben im Beitrag
schon gehört sie waren während der
coronazeit im Einsatz auch für die
Zivilbevölkerung was waren denn da so
die Einsatzgebiete die Einsatzgebiete
haben sich erstreckt einerseits
militärische Einrichtungen und im
zivilen Bereich von Kindergärten
angefangen über Schulen bis zum
Highlight kann man fast sagen dass
postverteilerzentrum Hagenbrunn wo wir
einen Großeinsatz gehabt haben dort war
ja ein Corona Cluster wie kann man sich
denn das vorstellen sie haben die Viren
quasi dort entfernt ja richtig also
prinzipiell zum Einsatz an sich wir
bekommen eine Alarmierung ja versuchen
so viele Informationen vorab zu
generieren
was auf uns zukommt und treffen dann
unsere Vorkehrungen wir richten unsere
Ausrüstung her und dann fahren wir zum
Einsatzort dort angekommen wird dann
beurteilt noch mal wo sind die sensiblen
Punkte wo sind die Hotspots wenn man so
sagen möchte der Kontamination so wie
wir es im fachjugo nennen und dort wird
dann angesetzt und die kontaminiert bzw
desinfiziert ja was kann der Mama sonst
noch man sieht ein riesen Gerät
verschiedene Container erklären Sie mir
das bitte wir haben hier eben das
Deckungssystem Mammut ja wir haben wie
sie hier hinten sehen können drei
Container drauf im ersten Container
haben wir Waffen und Geräte die
Kontamination kurz beschrieben dass sind
die ist das Modul wo man Fahrzeuge
Luftfahrzeuge Eisenbahnen die
kontaminieren können das zweite Modul
der mittlere Container ist die
Kleingeräte Deko mit einer Vakuumkammer
was so viel bedeutet wir haben jetzt da
die Fähigkeit dass wir auch Handys
Laptops de kontaminieren können und
diese nach der Dekontamination noch
einsatzfähig sind ja und wir sie wieder
verwenden können und der dritte
Container der kleinste von uns aus
gesehen rechts ist die die Kontamination
das ist das was wenn man sich meistens
was man meistens aus Videos oder Filmen
oder Fotos kennt das ist einfach ein
großer Platz aufgebaut mit einem
Duschzelt kann man sagen wo Personen
durchgeschleust werden und einer
Dekontamination zugeführt werden
das von so was von uns hier denn jetzt
zurück ins Schule zu dir Rebecca vielen
Dank Saskia ja Herr general Maja wir
wollen uns noch ein bisschen vertiefen
wie wichtig ist denn so eine ABC Abwehr
nämlich gerade in der Pandemie
das ist natürlich eine unserer
wesentlichen Kompetenzen dass wir im
atomaren biologischen und chemischen
Bereich eine Expertise aufgebaut haben
die wir jetzt auch in der Pandemie haben
nützen können
wir sollten aber nicht vergessen dass es
natürlich im Rahmen der vorher auch
schon genannten Hybriden Bedrohungen zu
Dingen in Europa gekommen ist wo
plötzlich Giftgas oder mit der
Nervengift Anschläge passieren und das
ist ein typisches Alleinstellungsmerkmal
für militärische Organisationen das
sieht man damit umgehen können müssen
oder denken wir daran dass es unter
Umständen auch zu einer Verstrahlung
kommen könnte mit der Nuklearmaterial
und da rede jetzt dann nicht nur von
einem Atomkraftwerk sondern das es
müssen schon auch bewusst sein dass das
eine reale ernst zu nehmen der
terroristische Bedrohung ist dass hier
entweder mit Kampfstoffen oder auch mit
douklamaterial hantiert wird aber es
kommt ja das nicht so häufig vor wird
wie kann man sich das vorstellen diese
Truppe wie arbeitet die bereiten
bereiten die sich vor
was nicht fand ihn ins Ausland schauen
wie das andere Länder machen oder oder
wie kann man sich diese Arbeit
vorstellen also auf der internationalen
Bühne haben wir hier sehr gute Kontakte
vor mit der Bundeswehr aber natürlich
auch mit Tschechien und auch auf dem
Balkan das ist immer das eine und so wie
die militärische Organisation als er
ganzer sich im Frieden darauf
vorbereitet dass sie dann im Einsatz
besteht macht es auch die ABC
abwehrtruppe nur ist hier noch einmal
draufzulegen sehr hohe
individuelle Expertise der Experten in
den Bereich vom Beispiel wenn es um
Bio-Waffen geht oder um chemische
Kampfstoffe die die Soldaten haben
müssen aber auch dort setzen wir zum
Beispiel er spürer
Grundwehrdiener ein die
zusammen der ABC abwehrkompanten im
Dienst versehen wie viele Leute gibt es
da bei dieser
apclichen das abc-abwehrzentrum das ist
in Korneuburg und wir haben über das
Bundesgebiet verstreut vier weitere ABC
abwehrkompanien im Endeffekt immer
abwechselnd in einer Einsatzbereitschaft
sind wie lange dauerte die Ausbildung
also wenn man jetzt sagt ich
interessiere mich jetzt dafür ich möchte
das gerne machen was muss man da machen
der Grundwehrdiener der rückzahl ABC
Abwehr ein und wird dann dort sechs
Monate ausgebildet und rüstet dann ab
der Unteroffizier Durchlauf ganz normal
seine Kader Anwärter und Kader
Ausbildung die über mehrere Monate
eigentlich eineinhalb Jahre am Anfang
und dann halt an den Jobtraining
passiert und der Offizier braucht dann
der Militärakademie drei Jahre und kann
dann zur ABC Abwehr nach der
Ausmusterung von der Wiener Neustädter
Militärakademie übernommen werden aber
wie kompliziert ist diese Ausbildung
also muss speziellen Vorkenntnisse
bringen oder
die Dinge die man hier braucht die kann
man alle beim Bundesheer erlernen
jetzt hat man noch mal vielleicht zurück
jetzt denkt man sich trotzdem österreich
hat jetzt nicht so ein Problem mit mit
atoman oder biologischen Waffen
warum wird das da trotzdem vom
Bundesheer so verfolgt also warum wird
das warum gibt es diese Einheit
ja also die die Hauptaufgabe da wird sie
Abwehrkräfte wie alle anderen Kräfte des
Bundesheeres ist eben im Einsatz ihre
Aufgabe zu bestehen und wir kommen aus
einer Zeit wo man sehr stark mit
nuklearer Auseinandersetzung hat rechnen
müssen und auch die C-Waffen gibt es
nach wie vor wir brauchen nur nach
Syrien schon oder auch solsbury der
Anschlag das ist nicht auszuschließen
und natürlich hoch gefährlich nicht nur
für die Soldaten sondern auch für die
Zivilbevölkerung und somit ist das ganz
ganz wichtig dass wir diese Expertise im
Haus selbst haben beim Endeffekt wenn
man es dann braucht wird das nur
verfügbar sein wenn man selber hat nur
vom Bundesheer oder gibt es da noch
andere Stellen in Österreich die das
auch können also mit denen sie zusammen
in der Art wie wir das machen machen es
nur wir also die Dekontamination in dem
Umfang und in der Qualität wir arbeiten
natürlich sehr eng auch mit der
Forschung zusammen mit dem seibersdorfer
Zentrum um eines zu nennen und natürlich
wird regelmäßig auch mit den Feuerwehren
geübt die aber natürlich dadurch dass
ich eine Feuerwehr sind eine andere
Grundausrichtung haben als die ABC
abwehrtruppe vielen Dank Herr generalm
ja der österreichische Nationalfeiertag
jetzt seit 1965 jedes Jahr begangen wir
feiern an diesem Tag Österreichs immer
während der Neutralität in diesem Jahr
wie bereits im vergangenen wird der
Nationalfeiertag allerdings von der
corona-pandemie überschattet
Gesundheitskrise Wirtschaftskrise und
eine türkis grüne Regierungskrise mit
dem neuwahlgespenst das immer noch
herumgeistert wie sehen die
VertreterInnen der Oppositionsparteien
im Parlament SPÖ FPÖ und Neos dem
heutigen Tag mitten in dieser Krise
prinzitelbacher hat sich umgehört und
eine Art Fragebogen zum Tag und zur Lage
des Landes mit den Parteivorsitzenden
ausgefüllt
[Musik]
ja mittlerweile passiert hier ganz was
interessantes was wir beobachten nämlich
dass die Sportler von allen möglichen
Disziplinen jetzt gegenseitige Geräte
ausüben wir sind hier auf der Innenbahn
nicht nur die Fünfkämpfer sondern die zu
dokas und Karate Kämpfer
also jetzt sind wir ordentlich warm
anscheinend das ist warm geworden und
dieses ausprobieren das ist miteinander
dieses Kennenlernen der anderen
Sportarten ist auch wieder das was so
ganz ganz viel Spaß macht und vor allem
zeigt was die Fähigkeiten von den
anderen sind damit sie ihre Sportart
wirklich auf die Niveau ausüben können
ja jetzt haben wir auch dieses neue
diese ich sag's einmal ganz floppig
diese Hüpfburg
ist aber ein ist aber viel mehr ist
wirklich ein tolles Ding anspruchsvoller
absolut ja ich habe selber Lust dass
einmal auszuprobieren vielleicht
überwinde ich mich aber wir wollen
natürlich ein bisschen erfahren es ist
ja nicht kein Spielgerät sondern es hat
eine Ernst Hintergrund und ich darf dann
noch einmal unseren den Leiter des
heeressportzentrum bitten zu uns
das hat ja eine Entwicklungsarbeit
hinter sich diese diese diese
Anlage die wir hier sehen ja das ist
richtig wir waren lange auf der Suche
dass wir so geeignetes Sportgerät mehr
oder weniger finden es ist uns dann
letztendlich gelungen so in der
Konfiguration wie es jetzt hinter uns
aufgebaut ist
anzuschaffen und wie schon richtig
erwähnt war das ist kein Spielgerät
sondern man kann hier schon einmal in
einer anlernstufe simulieren wie
verschiedene Hindernisse zu überwinden
sind das heißt Schnelligkeit
Schnellkraft Beweglichkeit also das sind
alles so motorische Eigenschaften die
hier trainiert werden können und
eignet sich dieser Parcours hervorragend
das erste Mal ist es am Tag des Sportes
eingesetzt worden wo wird es geplant
dieses diese Anlage
einzusetzen wo kann man es ausprobieren
also eingesetzt wird es bei
sportlichen Großveranstaltungen und je
nach Platzangebot haben wir die
Möglichkeit dass wir diese vier Elemente
entweder zur Gänze aufstellen oder eben
nur eines je nachdem und unser Ziel ist
es dass wir bei solchen
Großveranstaltungen die Jugend zu Sport
begeistern ja das ist einmal unseres
unser primäres Anliegen und gerade in
Zeiten wie diesen ja wo Covic bedingt
sehr viel Sport nicht möglich war
ist es unser besonderes Anliegen hier
wieder Impulse zu setzen so dass die
Jugend für den Sport begeistert wird und
dann kommt noch dazu natürlich ist
dieser Parcours wenn man in sich
anschaut von der Eigenschaft dem das
hindernislaufes sehr ähnlich wenn wir
hier dann Jugendliche auch begeistern
können dass sie vielleicht dann beim
Hindernislauf bleiben also beim
militärischen Fünfkampf und dann diese
Sportart ausüben wollen
dann ist es uns auch sehr recht ja danke
Sport ist war schon im ersten Einsatz
wie ist es dort angekommen also extrem
gut es war sogar so dass wir dort quasi
Platzkarten vergeben mussten und
Zeitbeschränkungen aussprechen mussten
ja weil wenn man einmal in dem Element
drinnen ist und vor allem bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen haben wir das gesehen
dann ist es so dass die noch zehn
Minuten nicht herauskommen also da muss
man dann wirklich sagen damit andere
auch in den Genuss dieses Geräts kommen
dass man Zeitfenster einfach vorgibt an
das ist es nicht möglich also um die
Frage zu beantworten es ist sehr gut
angenommen worden dieses Angebot sie
selber auch schon ausprobiert
selbstverständlich ja also ich musste
das Gerät zumindest abnehmen ja und dann
und dann freigeben ja alles klar und
wurde die Zeit gestoppt die Zeit wurde
gestoppt das bleibt aber ein Geheimnis
ja
da wäre es besser die Zeiten der
Leistungssportler dann vielleicht zu
erwähnen nicht die des Kommandanten ja
aber auch hier sehen wir es wird
angenommen von den Schülern der
Fachschule für Führung die sind eifrig
dabei die Judokas machen ein bisschen
Pause
jedes Element so effektiv wie möglich zu
überkommen das heißt bei jedem Mal noch
besser werden noch effektiver werden
also da merkt man schon dass dann auf
jeden Fall da der Ehrgeiz mit den Leuten
auch durchgeht vor allem auch mit dem
Profis ja absolut ja das sieht man ja
und so soll es auch sein
richtig ja dann ich habe vorher gesagt
eigentlich habe ich Lust ich sage mal
vor ich weiß jetzt mal probieren ja also
na dann erst doch gut oder
so eine Sekunde langsamer eine Sekunde
langsam
gewaschen und live kommentieren na das
also
damit
nach dieser Übergabe und nach meinem
Versuch übergebe ich dann wieder an die
ORF Kameras dem Andi war seine große
Freude und mir natürlich einer Größe
Freude hat auch Spaß gemacht mit mit Dir
hier diesen Sport hier zu gestalten mir
auch dankeschön das wird sich in Kürze
werden sich die ORF Kommentatoren dann
wieder melden und ich probiere es jetzt
einmal
fängt schon
gut an
über die erste Hürde drüber
die Brüder gehören mittlerweile zu den
bekannten und geschätzten Namen in der
österreichischen Kunst und Musikbranche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was passiert jetzt also jetzt gehen wir
in den nächsten
Kunden zum eigentlichen Höhepunkt der
Feierlichkeit über es beginnt jetzt dann
unmittelbar die Angelobung der 100
Rekruten die quasi repräsentativ für die
für den ganzen einrückungstermin
September und Oktober hier am
Heldenplatz sind
der Herr Bundespräsidentin Begleitung
des chefinenkanalstabschefs des
Bundeskanzlers und der
verbundesministerin schalten jetzt
Richtung
kommend zur Mitte des heldenplatzes
wir hören das ankündigungssignal
[Musik]
das
wir hören jetzt den Kommandanten der
Garde
[Musik]
der über alle eingetretenen Truppen
rechts
eine Ehrenformation und 100 Rekruten der
Garde zur feierlichen angelogen
woraus besteht sehr Ehrenformation
wir haben jetzt die Musik den singen
Druck und der ehrenkomponie
und hören jetzt die Bundesländer
[Musik]
nachdem die Bundesminister verklungen
ist wird jetzt die Stadtspitze der
Bundespräsident im Begleitung
Bundeskanzler der Bundesminister
Stefanie gallstadtchef und dahinter
haben wir gesehen den
Bürgermeister von Wien den Herrn
Vizekanzler den Adjutanten des
Bundespräsidenten und ehemaligen
Minister stalinger und dem
Militärkommandanten von Wien und weil
sie gefragt haben woraus besteht die
Ehrenformation sie ist jetzt noch
ergänzt und die archetatur
nachdem der also der Kommandant der
Garde selbst ausgerückt ist und sonst
ist es die gleiche Formation wie bei der
ganz niederlegungen zuvor
der Herr Oberleitner den wir vorher
immer groß bei der Meldung gesehen haben
ist jetzt eingetreten
[Musik]
also er steht in der Formation mit den
anderen dahinter die 100 Rekruten in
grün
[Musik]
auf einer Bühne leichter erhöht
die Ehrengäste begeben sich jetzt zu
ihren Plätzen auf der sogenannten
papstbühne der diesen Namen als dass sie
beim Papstbesuch verwendet wurde
dort befinden sich auch die anderen
Regierungsmitglieder die an der
feierlich an der Feier teilnehmen und
der einzelne Mann in der Mitte der
vorles ist eben da kann man dann liegt
jetzt die Verantwortung zur rechten Zeit
die richtigen Befehle zu gehen
ihre
[Musik]
so Flaggenparade
als Teil des diplomatischen Protokoll
[Musik]
Tradition dass man im Endeffekt
die der eigenen Truppe die eigene
Fahne zeigt und somit ist auch die
Staatsflagge Rot Weiß Rot mit dem Adler
hier am Heldenplatz aufzuziehen
Bestandteil jeder militärischen größeren
Feierlichkeiten
[Musik]
und
Herren
von Wien Herr Brigadier Magister Kurt
Wagener im Anschluss hören Sie die
Ansprache des Bürgermeisters und
Landeshauptmannes von Wien Herr Dr
Michael Luch ja general Mallorca
lobt was haben die denn bisher schon
alles erlebt und was kommt noch auf die
zu also die 100 exemplarisch oder
stellvertretenden grundverdiener die wir
hier auf der Bühne sehen haben jetzt
einmal die ersten knapp zwei Monate beim
Dienst im Bundesheer hinter sich
gebracht es geht um mal darum sich in
der militärischen Organisation
zurechtzufinden sich mit der Uniform
anzufreunden mit den sicher ungewohnten
Umgangsformen in einem relativ klar
hierarchisch organisierten Rahmen
zu leben und die Aufgabe in den ersten
zwei Monaten ist an und für sich den
Soldaten das Überleben auf den
Gefechtsfeld zu ermöglichen das heißt
sie haben die Basics einmal mitbekommen
sie können mit denke wer umgehen sie
sind auch in der Lage zum Beispiel ihre
Schutzmaske gegen apc-bedrohungen
Hand zu haben und Sie können wie Sie
sehen entsprechend auch schon
exertiermässig marschieren
und um sich im militärischen Leben
einigermaßen gut zurechtfinden die Miliz
ist es sehr wichtig für das
österreichische Bundesheer wie viele von
diesen Rekruten haben den oder leckenden
Blut und sagen sie wollen eigentlich in
der Mini zweiter machen sie wollen
irgendwie weiterhin fürs Bundesheer auch
tätig sein also nachdem nach den
offensiven das Show transportiert wurde
dass man erstens das Bundesheer doch
wieder braucht und auch das finanziell
unterstützen möchte
haben wir schon gemerkt dass das
Interesse am österreichischen Bundesheer
sowohl berufsmäßig wie auch im
Berufssoldaten wie auch beim bei der
Miliz zugenommen hat sie wissen ja dass
die Truppenübungen ausgesetzt sind aber
gerade im Bereich der
machen wir große Anstrengungen die Leute
bei uns schon anzuwerben und ich kann
Ihnen sagen dass gerade die Garde die er
sehr viele Grundwehrdiener im Laufe des
Jahres in der Ausbildung hat hier sehr
erfolgreich zum Beispiel für die zwei
Wiener jägerbatterie ohne auch Miliz
wird und das Thema wird gut angenommen
und wir haben auch eine eine offensive
gestartet stärker die Miliz in die
Einsätze zu bringen ganz so wesentlicher
Punkt das das unter dem Schlagwort mein
Dienst für Österreich können für relativ
gute Bezahlung die Soldaten nach ihrem
sechs Monate Grundwehrdienst nachher
drei Monate in den Assistenzeinsatz
gehen zum Beispiel an die
burgenländische Grenze und verdienen
dort auch ein recht gutes Geld der große
Vorteil ist auch dass wir
die als Gemeinschaft für sechs Monate
zusammen
ihren Dienst absolviert haben hier
gemeinschaftlich an die Grenze schicken
somit keine umfassende langen
einsatzvorbereitungen notwendiges und
sich die Leute kennen und dann das
Erlebte aus dem grundworddienst dorthin
mitnehmen kommen wir vielleicht noch zum
Thema Frauen und Bundesheer jetzt haben
wir da heute die angelogen von 100
Rekruten sind da auch Frauen dabei ja
diesmal leider nicht
fragen Sie mich nicht warum das jetzt
heuer genauso der Fall ist wir haben bei
den Frauen und dem Anwerben von
weiblichen Personalrat für den
militärischen Bereich sicher noch Luft
nach oben das ist mit vier Prozent noch
nicht dort wo wir hinwollen das Ziel ist
dass wir zehn Prozent mittelfristig
erreichen andererseits ist das
Bundesheer schon ein attraktiver
Arbeitgeber offensichtlich schon auch
für die weibliche Bevölkerung beim
zivilen Bereich haben wir ein gutes
Drittel
auch gleich das Geld für gleiche
Leistung glaube ich das Bundesheer zahlt
nämlich hundertprozentig gleiches Geld
für gleiche Leistung das heißt der
gestrige Equal Pay Day der ist bei uns
tatsächlich am 31 Dezember aber was tut
das Bundesheer damit vielleicht noch
mehr Frauen irgendwie das machen wollen
wie das schaffen sie für Incentives es
ist natürlich jetzt es hat sich gezeigt
über die Erfahrungen die wir gemacht
haben dass es notwendig ist die Frauen
auf das was sie hier erwartet
entsprechend vorzubereiten und dazu
haben wir auch begonnen vorgestapelt
nicht nur Informationen sondern auch
ganz gezielt vor allem auf den Sport und
die sportliche grundbefähigung
hinzuwirken und hier ein Förderprogramm
errichtet dass im Endeffekt auch ich
muss Sie leider unterbrechen ja in
diesem Momenten starten am Heldenplatz
die Reden der menschenvertreter den
Anfang macht gemäß den Protokoll der
Wiener Bürgermeister Michael Ludwig von
der SPÖ
am Heldenplatz begrüßen kann ein Platz
der mit der Geschichte unseres Landes
ganz eng verwoben ist und war
die hellen aber auch die dunklen Seiten
unserer Geschichte
die sicher schwärzesten Tage waren als
das Nazi-Regime Besitz genommen hat von
diesem Platz und es war deshalb für uns
wichtig dass wir diesen Platz auch
definieren
nachdem dieses furchtbare Regime
Geschichte war am 8 mai am Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges in Europa am Ende
eines furchtbaren terrore schims dass
wir diesen Tag am 8 mai denken wir
werden hier jeden jedes Jahr ein fester
Freude machen ein Fest das daran
erinnert dass dies als furchtbare Regime
so viel Leid über die Menschen in der
ganzen Welt gebracht hat mit dem
furchtbaren Menschheitsverbrechen der
Shoa mit der Verfolgung und Vernichtung
vieler Frauen Männer Kinder
und am 15 Mai mit dem Staatsvertrag hat
es ebenfalls ein wichtiges Datum gegeben
dass im Belvedere stattgefunden hat und
in den 60er Jahren hat man überlegt was
wir ein geeigneter Nationalfeiertag ich
habe den 8 mai angesprochen als Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges in Europa und dem
Ende des Nazi-Regimes den 15 Mai den
Staatsvertrag der unterzeichnet wurde
von der österreichischen Bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit den signatamichten
man hat sich aber entschieden für den 26
Oktober
1955 ein Tag in dem der österreichische
Nationalrat beschlossen hat die
immerwährende Neutralität
und warum warum hat man sich gerade für
dieses Datum entschieden
deshalb weil es von Österreich selbst
bestimmt war diese Neutralität
anzunehmen in einer Zeit des Kalten
Krieges wo Wien
im Mittelpunkt Europas
direkt am Eisernen Vorhang gelegen
Brücken bauen konnte gerade auch als
neutrales Land Österreich und Wien im
Zentrum eines Europas das geteilt war
durch zwei Wirtschafts- und politische
Blöcke
in dieser Zeit hat das österreichische
Bundesheer schwierige Aufgaben zu
leisten gehabt ich denke an die
ungarn-krise 1956 oder auch die
Niederschlagung des sogenannten Prager
Frühlings 1968
aber auch noch am Beginn der 90er Jahre
als am Balkan Kriege geführt worden sind
und sich Panzer an der österreichischen
Grenze gegenüber gestanden sind
und natürlich ist es so dass die
Neutralität nach Ende des Kalten Krieges
und nach Aufhebung des Eisernen Vorhangs
eine andere Rolle bekommen hat
manche sprechen heute davon
dass es ein Schein eine Schein Existenz
ist diese Neutralität ein Untoter der
durch die österreichische Politik geht
ich bin nicht dieser Meinung weil ich da
Auffassung bin dass Österreich einen
wesentlichen Beitrag leisten kann als
neutrales Land
also eine Möglichkeit der Begegnung als
Brückenbauer überall dort wo es
Konflikte Kriege in der Welt gibt
einzuladen um hier Möglichkeiten
vorzufinden um Frieden zu schaffen
Bundeskanzler Bruno Kreisky und dem
damaligen Wiener Bürgermeister Leopold
Graz ist es gelungen die Vereinten
Nationen nach Wien zu holen es ist im
übrigen der einzige Sitz der UNO in der
Europäischen Union
50 internationale Organisationen haben
ihren Sitz in Wien gefunden und der
andere macht die oscd viele Frieden
schaffende Institutionen und
Organisationen
und von daher ist es eine Möglichkeit
die Neutralität einzusetzen
auch als Teil der österreichischen
Außenpolitik die nicht nur gesehen
werden darf als Innenpolitik sondern als
Ziel Frieden zu schaffen in der Welt
denn wir sind keine Insel der Seligen
wir alle wissen dass Kriege Konflikte in
der Welt Auswirkungen auch auf
Österreich haben
durch Terroranschläge oder auch durch
Migrationsbewegungen die österreich-
von daher das österreichische Bundesheer
schon sehr früh Verantwortung übernommen
um Frieden zu sichern in der Welt und
auch heute sind Angehörige des
österreichischen Bundesheeres in
Bosnien-Herzegowina im Kosovo in anderen
Teilen der Welt wie in Mali unterwegs um
Frieden sichernde Maßnahmen zu setzen
ein wertvoller Beitrag des
österreichischen
bundesheere um Frieden aufrecht zu
halten in der Welt und damit auch in
Österreich
diese Mission ist Teil der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung und das
österreichische Bundesheer schützt im
Rahmen dieser umfassenden
Landesverteidigung der österreichischen
Grenzen hat Frieden sichernde Maßnahmen
in der Welt ist aber auch Teil der
österreichischen Gesellschaft
nicht so wie in früheren Zeiten in
unserer Geschichte die weit zurückliegt
ein Fremdkörper in unserem Staat
nein das österreichische Bundesheer ist
Teil dieser
österreichischen Gesellschaft
ein Land das einen wertvollen Beitrag
leisten will in einem gemeinsamen
friedlichen Europa und von daher bedanke
ich mich auch beim österreichischen
Bundesheer gerade für die schwierige
Zeit jetzt hinter uns liegt
wir haben heute wieder eine
eingeschränkte Angelobung weil es Corona
gibt und weil wir Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
setzen müssen dass sich die Menschen
nicht anstecken
und auch heute wird es Möglichkeiten
geben sich impfen zu lassen nicht
zuletzt auch in der Hofburg und deutlich
zu machen das ist die einzige
Möglichkeit sich gegen dieses Virus zu
schützen
das österreichische Bundesheer hat
gerade in der schwierigsten Phase
mitgeholfen diese corona-krise mit zu
bewältigen und ich bedanke mich weil das
österreichische Bundesheer auch Teil der
Helfer Wiens ist Teil eines
Sicherheitsnetzes in unserer Stadt von
40 Organisationen die mit dazu beitragen
dass die Sicherheit in unserer Stadt in
unserem Land gewährleistet ist und was
darum geht wie in einem Zahnrad die
Organisationen einzuhängen aufgrund
institutioneller Vernetzungen aber auch
langjähriger persönlicher Kontakte die
so hilfreich sind wenn es dann darum
geht konkret in der Krise Maßnahmen zu
setzen
ich möchte mich aber abschließend ganz
besonders herzlich bedanken für eine
sehr unmittelbare Kooperation
es bringen derzeit am Schneeberg 100
Hektar Wald
es sind die
wasserschutzwälder der Stadt Wien
die Wälder werden auch von der Stadt
Wien betreut das sind viele
Forstarbeiter vor Ort
und sie können sich vorstellen dass ein
solcher Brand von 100 Hektar alle
fordert und ich bin sehr froh dass diese
Kooperation zwischen den Mitarbeitern
der Stadt Wien den örtlichen Feuerwehren
aber auch dem österreichischen
Bundesheer sehr sehr gut funktioniert
ein Zeichen dafür ist das über die
Bundesländer Grenzen hinweg die
Zusammenarbeit das Miteinander dann
funktioniert ganz besonders notwendig
ist in Krisen in Katastrophensituationen
es ist unter anderem ein Black Hawk
schon vor Ort so viel ich weiß wird noch
ein zweiter zu Mittag nachstoßen und
wird mithelfen diesen Brand zu löschen
ich meine ein schönes Bild der
Gemeinsamkeit einen Brand gemeinsam
löschen in einem gemeinsamen Österreich
ein Miteinander dass wir immer in den
Mittelpunkt rücken sollen
und das zeigt dass wir in Österreich
eine Gesellschaft sind die insbesondere
in schwierigen Zeiten zusammensteht
deshalb hochgeschätzte Rekruten wünsche
ich Ihnen eine interessante vielleicht
auch spannende Zeit beim
österreichischen Bundesheer
aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich sagen
vieles waren Erfahrungen
die spannend waren manche weniger auch
Leerläufe haben meinen Alltag beim
österreichischen Bundesheer geprägt aber
es war vor allem eine Zeit wo
Kameradschaft und Miteinander im
Vordergrund gestanden sind und wo ich
viel mitgenommen habe für mein weiteres
Leben das wünsche ich Ihnen auch vor
allem auch eine unfallfreie Zeit und
dass sie diese Zeit gut verbringen ich
bin stolz auf sie dass sie sich
einsetzen für unsere Republik Österreich
für unser Heimatland
und ich weiß diesen Stolz teilig mit den
Familienangehörigen die heute
hergekommen sind und die bei dieser
Angelobung mit dabei sind und ich
ebenfalls ganz herzlich willkommen
heißen möchte aus allen neuen
Bundesländern in diesem Sinne wünsche
ich Ihnen alles Gute es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer es lebe ein
gemeinsames friedliches Europa es lebe
unser Heimatland die Republik Österreich
[Musik]
es folgt jetzt die Rede von
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
von der
spricht Bundeskanzler Magister Alexander
Schallenberg im Anschluss hören Sie den
marsch-
Geistlichkeit sehr geehrter Herr
Bundespräsident Frau
Nationalratspräsidentin Mitglieder der
Bundesregierung sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
fallen aber heute sehr geehrte
Rekruten liebe Angehörige
der 26 Oktober das ist ein ganz
besonderer Tag es ist ein besonderer Tag
für unsere Republik und insbesondere für
unser Herr denn der 26 Oktober ist jener
Tag an dem wir die immerwährende
Neutralität unseres Landes feiern und
dabei auch jene die bereit sind dieses
hohe Gut zu verteidigen nämlich unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
in den vergangenen zwei Jahren standen
für unser her zwei Themen massiv im
Fokus
erstens die Bewältigung der
corona-pandemie
erinnern wir uns gemeinsam zurück als
wir erstmalig von diesem neuartigen
Virus gehört haben
als wir begonnen haben Masken zu tragen
und erste
Einschränkungen zum Schutz unserer
Gesundheit in Kauf nehmen mussten
von Beginn an war unser Herr zur Stelle
seine ist die berufssoldatinnen und
Soldaten die Grundwehrdiener von denen
Tausende länger dienen mussten die milit
Soldatinnen und Soldaten die erstmals
aufgeboten wurden erstmals in der
Geschichte unserer Republik oder auch
die Zivilbediensteten meines Ressorts
die so oft über ihre persönlichen
Grenzen über ihre persönlichen
Leistungsgrenzen
hinauswachsen mussten
sie waren immer da
von der kompletten Übernahme eines
Pflegeheims in der Steiermark bis hin
zur Umsetzung der unzähligen Test und
impfstraßen oder der Einreisekontrollen
sie waren immer da
von der maskenprüfung bis hin zur
Desinfektion etlicher Gebäude
zurückholung von Österreicherinnen und
Österreichern aus Hochrisiko Regionen
sie waren immer da
auch wenn es gleichzeitig um den Schutz
unserer Grenze gegen
illegale Migration geht oder die
Unterstützung bei den Hochwassern und
der anderen Naturkatastrophen so wie sie
jetzt gerade wieder erleben müssen in
Reichenau an der Rax und ich befürchte
dass wir den historischer Einsatz auch
werden müssen mit vier Hubschraubern die
wir so zur Bekämpfung von Waldbrand wohl
noch nie im Einsatz hatten
ja oder auch im Ausland in 15 Missionen
mit rund 1000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten
sie waren und sie sind immer da
sie haben etliche Millionen
Arbeitsstunden geleistet nicht für unser
Herr nicht für ihr Gehalt und schon gar
nicht für mich als Ministerin
nein für sie sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
und wenn Sie sich eine Botschaft vom
heutigen Tag mitnehmen dann bitte ich
Sie darum dass es eben diese ist
dass unser Herr immer für sie da ist
immer für Sie und Ihre Lieben da ist
das war während oder ist während der
Pandemie so dass wir doch in Zukunft so
sein dass verspreche ich Ihnen und das
führt mich zum zweiten Bereich mit dem
wir beschäftigt waren nämlich jenen
Maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben ja
treffen mussten damit unser Herr eben
auch all diese Anforderungen bewältigen
kann und ich glaube da ist uns sehr
vieles gelungen denken wir an die
dreimalige Steigerung des heeresbudgets
auf eine Rekordhöhe ganz offen unser
Herr wurde jahrelang jahrzehntelang
heruntergespart schlecht geredet damit
ist Schluss wir haben eine Trendwende
eingeläutet gemeinsam eine Trendwende
eingeläutet und befinden uns nun
erstmals seit Jahrzehnten in einer
Aufwärtsbewegung mit diesen Mitteln mit
diesen Mitteln wollen wir insbesondere
in den Bereichen der Terrorabwehr der
ABC und cyberabwehr der
Katastrophenabwehr sowie in der
Modernisierung der Miliz investieren und
unsere bereit machen für die Bedrohungen
für die Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
ich spreche damit von einem
sonderinvestitionsvolumen von über 600
Millionen Euro aber auch in die
Ausrüstung und in die Infrastruktur
unserer Kasernen müssen wir investieren
das ist dringend notwendig weil so lange
nicht wirklich etwas getan wurde seit
meinem Amtsantritt haben wir bereits 250
Millionen Euro in die Sanierung
Modernisierung die Herstellung der
Autarkie weil ich da gerade Blackout vor
mir lese investiert auch in die
Ökologisierung der Kasernen das werden
bis zum Jahr 2025 über 800 Millionen
Euro sein
ja und sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
auch in moderne Waffensysteme
investieren wir und das werden wir auch
weiterhin tun denn und das ist glaube
ich wichtig an dieser Stelle auch klar
zu stellen all die Assistenzaufgaben und
Unterstützungsleistungen die wir in der
Pandemie bei Naturkatastrophen erfüllen
das sind Nebenaufgaben für unser Herr
die wir auch erfüllen müssen ohne Frage
aber es sind Nebenaufgaben unsere
Kernaufgabe ist die militärische
Landesverteidigung das heißt mit der
Waffe unser Land und alles was wir
lieben zu verteidigen das müssen wir tun
und das werden wir tun
aber ich glaube wir dürfen uns keiner
Illusion hingeben dass wir uns alleine
gegen jede Bedrohung unserer Zeit
verteidigen können das glaube ich wäre
ein fataler Trugschluss das gilt nicht
nur für uns sondern für jedes Land in
der Europäischen Union und daher möchte
ich auch hier in aller Deutlichkeit
sagen die Europäische Union muss
aufhören nur über gemeinsame
sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik zu
reden und beginnen diese Sicherheit der
Bevölkerung auch zu liefern wir sind
bereit dafür wir sind bereit unseren
Beitrag zu leisten und werden uns auch
weiterhin für ein starkes für ein
sicheres Europa einsetzen
aber nicht nur in Europa auch hier in
Österreich müssen wir Maßnahmen treffen
Maßnahmen treffen um noch treffsicherer
zu werden und effektiv verhelfen zu
können
mit dem
krisensicherheitsgesetz ist uns heute im
sonderministerrat ein großer Schritt
gelungen die Behörden werden noch besser
zusammenarbeiten die Vorbereitung auf
Einsätze wir deffizienter werden und
unser Bundesheer kann einen noch
größeren Beitrag leisten dieses Gesetz
das wir gemeinsam auf den Weg gebracht
haben das wird der Meilenstein sein in
der österreichischen
Sicherheitspolitik denn nur mit ganz
klaren Zuständigkeiten mit genutzten
Synergien und mit treffsicheren
Maßnahmen werden wir den Bedrohungen und
Aufgaben der Zukunft
entgegentreten können
Geist auch eine sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren damit wir all das erfüllen können
damit auch die Investitionen treffsicher
sind brauchen wir auch die passenden
Strukturen und auch dieser
Herausforderung haben wir uns gestellt
und vor einigen Monaten erstmalig eine
Reform für die Truppe und nicht der
Truppe eingeläutet das Ziel dieser
Reform ist es den Verwaltungsapparat
schlanker zu machen und ihn von einem
reinen Verwaltungsapparat zu einer
Service und einer Führungsstelle für
unser Bundesheer weiterzuentwickeln
sie sehen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wir haben viel zu tun wir haben sehr
viel vor wir investieren wie Arbeiten am
massiven Verbesserungen für unser Herr
das tun wir nicht zum selbst Zweck
sondern um sie zu schützen
aber nun
meine sehr geehrten
Rekruten zu Ihnen
sie sind die Protagonisten des heutigen
Tages den sie werden heute ihren Eid auf
die Republik leisten und gelobene
Republik Österreich unserem Vaterland zu
dienen und seine Bevölkerung zu schützen
und das sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
das ist etwas unglaublich wertvolles und
wichtiges denn
und das ist meine tiefste Überzeugung
ein Land ein Land ist verloren wenn es
keine Menschen gibt die bereit sind ihm
zu dienen und es im Ernstfall zu
verteidigen und sie geschätzte Rekruten
sie gehören genau zu diesen Menschen
dafür gebührt ihnen unser aller Dank
aber und ich glaube das muss ihnen auch
bewusst sein das bedeutet auch dass die
Republik ihnen Vertrauen schenkt ihnen
sehr viel Vertrauen schenkt und ihnen
auch viel Verantwortung übergibt und
diese Verantwortung diese Verantwortung
die sehen Sie hier
bei ihnen bei ihren Angehörigen
denn sie sind es die von nun an die von
nun an verantwortlich sind
verantwortlich sind für den Schutz Ihrer
Liebsten ihrer Mitmenschen ja unserer
wunderschönen Republik
nehmen Sie diese Verantwortung ernst
es ist womöglich die wichtigste
Verantwortung die man übernehmen kann
sehr geehrte Rekruten ich wünsche Ihnen
eine lehrreiche Zeit eine fordernde Zeit
eine erlebnisreiche vor allem aber auch
eine spannende Zeit bei unserem
Bundesheer ich bin überzeugt davon dass
es eine Zeit sein wird dann die sie sich
ihr restliches Leben erinnern werden
ich habe damals bei meiner Angelobung
durch den Herrn Bundespräsidenten mich
mich gefragt was eigentlich meine
Hauptaufgabe sein wird als
Verteidigungsministerin und ich habe
eigentlich eine sehr einfache eine sehr
simple Antwort auf diese Frage gefunden
verteidigen was wir lieben unsere
Mitmenschen und unser wunderschönes
Heimatland
Rekruten machen Sie dies nun auch zu
ihrer Aufgabe
es lebe das österreichische Bundesheer
es lebe die Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
und jetzt spricht es gleich Alexander
schallenberger übrigens erst seit 15
Tagen als Bundeskanzler im
Amt der Bundespräsident
geschätzte Ehrengäste sehr geehrte
Soldatinnen und Soldaten vor allem liebe
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher hier
am Heldenplatz und zu Hause von
Bildschirmen
also am heutigen Tag im Jahre 1955
unsere immer wären der Neutralität als
einer der Grundsätze unserer
Bundesverfassung vom Nationalrat
beschlossen wurde wann Österreich der
war der gesamte europäische Kontinent
von den Auswirkungen des Zweiten
Weltkriegs noch schwer gezeichnet heute
66 Jahre später können wir in einer
starken einer wohlhabenden einer
gefestigten Republik im Herzen eines
geeinten Europas leben
Nationalfeiertag ist aber nicht nur ein
Tag zum Feiern ist auch eine Gelegenheit
zum Innehalten zur Reflektion zu
Selbstreflexion und so ein Innehalten
erscheint gerade in der jetzigen
Situation sinnvoll
Diskussionen und Debatten auch hitzige
und kontroversielle sind das
Schmiermittel jeder offenen
pluralistischen Gesellschaft
bei aller auch berechtigten
Emotionalität solche Debatten sollten
aber nie vergessen was für ein Glück wir
haben in einem Land wie Österreich leben
zu dürfen ein Land wunderbarer
Landschaft und großartiger Kultur ein
Land in dem wir alle Grund- und
Freiheitsrechte genießen können mit dem
Freiheit und Demokratie herrschen darum
beneiden uns viele Länder dieser Welt
ist ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit
wir verdanken dass einem starken
Fundament das seit 45 gelegt und immer
weiter befestigt wurde ein Fundament an
dem wir alle jeder einzelne von uns
unseren Anteil haben
wir sollten daher diesen Tag auch nutzen
um all jene zu gedenken all jenen zu
danken die in der Vergangenheit diese
Basis gelebt haben damit wir heute in
Freiheit Sicherheit und Wohlstand in
Österreich leben können
sehr geehrte Rekruten in wenigen Minuten
werden Sie Ihr treuer Gelöbnis auf der
Republik Österreich leisten
sie werden dabei unter anderem geloben
mit all ihren Kräften der Republik
Österreich und dem österreichischen Volk
zu dienen
das ist in meinen Augen vielleicht eines
der schönsten Gelöbnisse dass man
abgeben kann
ein Gelöbnis dass ich selber mit anderen
Worten vor wenigen Tagen als
Bundeskanzler von Bundespräsidenten
abgeben durfte
dem eigenen Land
der eigenen Gemeinschaft nach besten
Wissen und Gewissen mit all seinen
Kräften dienen zu dürfen
ist eine wunderschöne Aufgabe
aber ist eine Aufgabe die auch mit
großer Verantwortung einhergeht
eine Verantwortung der Sie sich lieber
Rekruten sehr wohl bewusst sind
eine Verantwortung die wir uns auf allen
Ebenen der Politik immer wieder in
Erinnerung rufen müssen
keine auf politischer Ebene darf glauben
dass sie sich ja einseitig ausnehmen
kann das ist quasi ein Opt-Out ein
Aussteigerprogramm von deiner
gesellschaftspolitischen Verantwortung
gibt
dieses Verantwortungsgefühl muss ich
gerade in einer gesamtgesellschaftlichen
Herausforderung wieder Bekämpfung der
Pandemie zeigen aber
sie muss sich auch bei anderen akuten
Herausforderungen zeigen Werte beim
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
und gerade das österreichische
Bundesheer trägt diesen Gedanken dieses
Dienens für das Gemeinwohl in sich
wir wissen daher in Österreich dass wir
uns immer voll und ganz auf unser
Bundesheer verlassen können und das ist
ein gutes Gefühl
denken wir nur und es wurde schon
erwähnt an die corona-pandemie an den
schrecklichen Terroranschlag letztes
Jahr an lawinenkatastrophen
Hochwasserkatastrophen
oder an die Kernaufgabe des Bundesheeres
die umfassende Landesverteidigung
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind
immer zur Stelle wenn sie gebraucht
werden im Inn wie im Ausland und mit all
ihren Kräften mit großen Erfolg unserem
Land und seiner Bevölkerung zu dienen
diese tolle Arbeit verdient unsere
Wertschätzung und verdient unseren
Respekt
sie verdient aber auch gute Ausrüstung
tauglicher Kasernen
und angemessene Entlohnung daher ist es
umso fröhlicher dass die
Verteidigungsministerin heuer zum
dritten malen Folge das höchste Budget
für das Bundesheer ausverhandelt hat
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
die Herausforderungen der letzten Jahre
insbesondere die Pandemie und der
Terroranschlag in Wien haben uns
deutlich vor Augen geführt dass wir
keine Insel der Seligen sind die da
irgendwo außen vor ist und von
internationalen Entwicklungen unberührt
bleibt
all diese Entwicklungen und Ereignisse
haben auch bestehende Schwächen im
gesamtstaatlichen agierenden
Krisenzeiten aufgezeigt
und für mich bedeutet Politik die
richtigen Lehren zu ziehen damit man für
die nächste Krise besser gewappnet ist
und so ist es auch hier mit dem heute im
Ministerrat vorgestellten
krisensicherheitsgesetz haben wir die
richtigen lernen gezogen es werden
Strukturen mit klaren Zuständigkeiten
geschaffen die koordinierungsmechanismen
werden gestrafft und dadurch eine
raschere Abstimmung Reaktion in allen
Bereichen unserer nationalen Sicherheit
gewährleistet
für mich ist dabei als Bundeskanzler
eine Sache ganz klar
unsere nationale Sicherheit hat keine
Parteifarbe wenn Sie eine Farbe hat dann
ist es rot-weiß rot wir werden daher in
den nächsten Wochen dieses Gesetz
konstruktiv mit allen im Nationalrat
vertretenen Parteien verhandeln wir
werden das Bundesregierung alles daran
setzen dass die Sicherheit für alle
Menschen in unserem Land bestmöglich
gewährleistet ist
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
von Henry Ford ist der Spruch
überliefert wenn alle zusammen nach
vorne schauen kommt Erfolg von selbst
gerade in der corona-krise hat sich
gezeigt dass wir das Virus nur besiegen
können wenn wir zusammenarbeiten wenn
wir aufeinander Rücksicht nehmen wenn
wir alle zusammen nach vorne schauen
letztes Jahr an diesem Tag war die
Verfügbarkeit des der
corona-schutzimpfung noch einer Hoffnung
heute
haben wir diese Impfung und sie wirkt
an all jene Menschen die noch zögern die
sich noch unsicher sind die noch glauben
zu warten zu müssen möchte ich
appellieren bitte lassen Sie sich impfen
bitte schützen sie sich sie schützen
damit auch alle anderen Menschen in
diesem Land ihre Familie ihre Freunde
ihre Arbeitskollegen
nur gemeinsam können wir diesen Spuk am
Ende bereiten und damit unsere Rückkehr
zum Normalität fortsetzen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren Sicherheit
Gesundheit Familie und
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt das ist
das Wesentliche das ist das was uns
ausmacht
vielen Dank an alle die dazu im
täglichen Beitrag leisten wir können
stolz sein auf das was wir in Österreich
geleistet haben gemeinsam ich wünsche
Ihnen allen einen schönen
Nationalfeiertag
es lebe die Republik Österreich und das
Leben unser gemeinsames Europa ich danke
Ihnen
jetzt der
[Musik]
und weil protokollarisch am höchsten
folgt jetzt die Rede von Bundespräsident
Alexander van der Bellen
danach spielt die Gardemusik eine
Fanfare
sehr geehrte Herren und Festgäste meine
Damen und Herren
vor allem aber sehr geehrte Rekruten
sie werden heute an diesem
Nationalfeiertag ihr Gelöbnis als Soldat
ablegen sie werden ihren Dienst antreten
ihren Dienst am Land
dem Land dienen
ein schöner Ausdruck der Bundeskanzler
Schallenberg
hat das auch schon gestreift
dieser Ausdruck weist darauf hin dass
die dienende Person anerkennt dass es
außerhalb der persönlichen Bedürfnisse
noch einen höheren Zweck gibt der es
eben Wert ist seine eigenen Interessen
zunächst einmal hin anzustellen
und insofern hochgeschätzte Rekruten
sind sie für uns alle ein Vorbild
auch die Politik mich selbst
eingeschlossen kann sich an ihnen ein
Beispiel nehmen denn auch der Zweck der
Politik ist es dem Land zu dienen danke
dass Sie uns heute daran erinnern
meine Damen und Herren
vor welchen sicherheitspolitischen
Herausforderungen stehen wird
der ehemalige
Generalsekretär der UNO kofiannan hat
schon 2005 folgendes festgehalten
wenn es Not development without security
wer ist no security without development
Entwicklung und Sicherheit gehören
zusammen dieser gesamtheitliche Ansatz
sollte eigentlich gängige Praxis sein
man fragt sich aber ob dieses Wissen im
Krisen wie covid 19 oder beim Engagement
in Konfliktgebieten wirklich auch
umfassend angewandt worden ist
die verstörenden Bilder von Ende des
internationalen Engagements in
Afghanistan und in anderen Regionen
geben leider eine andere Antwort
und ich hoffe dass nun nicht so
Tagesroutine übergegangen wird sondern
die Lehren aus den aktuellen Krisen
gezogen werden auf nationaler Ebene
begrüße ich daher sehr und ausdrücklich
dass zur Gewährleistung einer
gesamtstaatlichen Vorgangsweise zu
Krisenvorsorge und Krisenbewältigung
bald einen entsprechendes
krisensicherheitsgesetz zu Umsetzung
gelangen wird
meine Damen und Herren vereinigen Wochen
war ich zu Besuch bei den Gebirgsjägern
in der wattenalition in Tirol und einmal
mehr war ich von der hohen Motivation
und dem ausgezeichneten Ausbildung Stand
unserer Soldatinnen und Soldaten sehr
beeindruckt
ein einsatzfähiges Bundesheer ist ein
elementarer Faktor um wer künftigen
Krisen wie etwa einen Blackout bei
cyberbedrohungen oder durch die
Klimakrise ausgelösten Naturkatastrophen
robust und entschlossen agieren zu
können
für die Erfüllung der in der
österreichischen Bundesverfassung
festgeschriebenen Aufgaben des
österreichischen Bundesheers muss daher
eine ausreichende ressourcenzuweisung
gewährleistet sein
sehr geehrte
sie legen also heute am Nationalfeiertag
ihr Gelöbnis als Soldat ab sie werden in
einem Herr dienen dass ich den Seelen
Freiheit Schutz der Demokratie Eintreten
für die Achtung der Menschenrechte Hilfe
für Katastrophenopfer sowie Engagement
bei internationalen friedensaufgaben
verschrieben hat
mit ihrem Dienst leisten sie einen
wertvollen und unverzichtbaren Beitrag
zum Schutz und zu Sicherheit aller
Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner unsere
Republik ich wünsche Ihnen von Herzen
für die Zeit ihres Wehrdienstes alles
Gute bleiben Sie gesund es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer es lebe
unsere Heimat die Republik Österreich es
lebe ein vereintes friedvolles Europa
ich danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in das heutigen Tages gleich geht's los
mit der Angelobung 100 Rekruten werden
angelobt in einem nicht corona-jahr
werden es etwa zehnmal so viele und
sofort danach werden die Eurofighter
über den Heldenplatz fliegen wir haben
ein Porträt eines eurofater Piloten für
Sie vorbereitet Patrick Wöss vom
überwachungsgeschwader Zeltweg nimmt Sie
mit auf einen Flug überwinden
wir überwachen und sichern unseren
Luftraum 24 Stunden 365 Tage im Jahr
wird von klein auf unbedingt in eurer
Seite fliegen
darum habe ich beworben der
militärealgymnasium habe dann dort
moderiert bin ganz normal eingerückt zum
Bundesheer und habe während dem Studium
an der Theresianischen Militärakademie
die selektionsschritte zum Piloten
gemacht und habe dann mit der
fliegerischen Ausbildung angefangen und
bin dieses Jahr fertig geworden als
einsatzbereit
ung und sprich in der
sicherheitspolizeilichen Assistenz
machen wir salopp gesagt das in der Luft
was die Polizei am Boden macht
das ist eine sehr große Ehre des eigenen
Luftfahrzeug oder den eigenen Kampfjet
fürs eigene Land zu fliegen und die
Lufthoheit zu behaupten
man kann sie das so verstellen der
österreichische Luft haben ist ab einer
gewissen Höhe rund um Ballungszentrum
Flughäfen freigabepflichtigen ist ein
Luftfahrzeug drinnen dass diese
Erlaubnis nicht hat bzw der Funkkontakt
zu diesem Luftfahrzeug nicht hergestellt
werden kann werden wir alarmiert und
untersuchen dieses Luftfahrzeug
durch das dass wir durch so viele
Ausbildungen im Ausland gehen und es
sehr sehr lange dauert ist natürlich der
erste Flug im heimischen Luftfahrzeug
über heimischen Boden ein ganz großer
Schritt und eine ganz große Erfahrung
nur Moses Jesus und Mohammed unsere
Heiligen gallidee und der erleuchteten
soll über jeden von euch sein der
Schöpfer möge ihnen Kraft und Weisheit
geben bei den Aufgaben diese zu
bewältigen haben mögen ihre eingesetzten
mitteleffektiv sein und sie zum Ziel
führen seit steht sie im friedlichen da
sind mit dem Glaubensweg somit in
Frieden mit Gott in Frieden mit Menschen
unabhängig von Rasse Glaube und Herkunft
und nicht zuletzt auch in Frieden mit
euch selbst die sprechende Zunge von uns
da hatten vom heiligenallee und das
gehirnde
gebetten gesehen es werden zwei
euroväter und eine C130 über den
Heldenplatz fliegen ist das einem
Premiere in der Form dass wir sie auch
gut sehen können ist es jedenfalls eine
pyramere wir wollten ja auch voriges
Jahr
ebenfalls den Überflug durchführen
allerdings wurde der nicht gesehen
aufgrund der Wolkendecke heuer ist uns
das Wetter holt und wir werden die 1030
und die beiden Eurofighter wohl
hoffentlich gut sehen hoffentlich oder
ist das schon fix dass wir sie sehen
werden ich gehe davon aus dass das
Wetter gut genug ist von wo starten die
Maschine eigentlich
die große Transportmaschine steht in
Linz Hörsching die treffen sich über
Tulln in einer Holding und kommen dann
Donau abwärts und schwenken dann grob
über das Burgtheater kommen werden sie
über den Heldenplatz
in wenigen Minuten an jedem Punkt der
Erde
in jedem Punkt Österreichs angelangt und
Piloten werden mehr Rücksicht darauf
nehmen müssen dass sie mit der
verhältnismäßig langsamer 1930
mitfliegen wie viele Zwischenfälle gibt
es eigentlich im österreichischen
Luftraum
erstaunlicherweise man würde das so
nicht glauben doch über 100 pro Jahr ich
muss leider unterbrechen die von Pfarre
kommt und markiert den feierlichen
angelogen
[Musik]
von recruit Elias Kasper gesprochen
nachdem die eingeteilten Rekruten wieder
eingetreten sind hören Sie die
Bundeshymne danach ertönt die
Europahymne und im Anschluss sehen Sie
einen Gruß der Luftstreitkräfte
in Singen in der Garde vortreten
eingeteilte Rekruten
ich glaube
mein Vaterland
die Republik Österreich
und sein Volk zu schützen
und mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe
den Gesetzen und den gesetzesrisiken
Treue und Gehorsam zu leisten
alle Befehle meiner Vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
und mit all meinen Kräften
der Republik Österreich
und in österreichischen Volker
zu dienen
Rekruten von hier
eingeteilte
in Singen in der Garde eintreten
[Musik]
zum Abspielen der Bundes- und Europa
ihre company schon
ihre Kompanie beim
Gegensatz zum letzten Jahr sehen wir
jetzt wie versprochen
sehr gut
230 und links und rechts davon
[Musik]
einfliegen eine Premiere in dieser Form
hat sich abgemeldet und die Flieger
sind im
wenigen Sekunden dann über den
Heldenplatz
und dann wird es aber richtig laut
gehabt
ein Wissensstand her nicht dann
hochziehen und die Nachbrenner
einschalten weil das
über Wien
nicht gut ist bisschen
keinen Applaus ich denke das wird den
jetzt aus akustischen Gründen vom
Heldenplatz nicht hören ich denke schon
dass die Zuschauer am hellen Platz auch
rotiert haben und ich denke dass das für
die insgesamte Veranstaltungen sehr
schöner
Abschluss war hier auch einen Gruß der
Luftstreitkräfte an die Rekruten und
auch an die anwesenden Ehrengäste zu
senden
und die fliegen dann wieder zurück
begeben sich jetzt dann wieder zurück an
ihre Ausgangsseite nach Zeltweg bzw nach
Herrsching und wie wir gehört haben
werden jetzt dann auch falschen
springendes Kommandos
wie lange fliegen die jetzt dann zurück
wenige Minuten dass die wieder zurück
sind die Distanzen im Luftlinie sehr
kurz sind
so da sehen wir jetzt noch da passiert
noch was was passiert jetzt die
Ehrenformation aus
weil er auch der Platz frei gemacht
werden muss für die Landung der
Kommandosoldaten
das heißt die ehrenkomponie mit der
Musik
marschiert aus hier sehen wir jetzt
Bilder aus dem
Hubschrauber
gesehen haben
vier Soldaten des jagdkommunismus
abgesetzt werden wir haben
kurzfristig also diese
Bilder ja gesehen wir haben kurzfristig
hier ein bisschen undisponiert und von
der Blackhawk sind wir auf ein
Transportflugzeug gegangen
weil der Hubschrauber zu dem vom
Bürgermeister von Wien erwähnten
Waldbrand abkommandiert worden ist und
es ist ein Problem dass man kurzfristig
sehr sehr flexibel und sehr rasch in dem
umdisponieren sie sind ja alle eine
Einsatzorganisation und worauf ein
bisschen hinweisen sollte ist jetzt
jetzt schon bei dieser ganzen Sache mit
dem Fallschirm Abschwung dass der Show
eine eine gute Leistung der
Kommandosoldaten ist hier über dem
Stadtgebiet abzuspringen wie kann man
das eigentlich teilen da gibt es ja auch
Winde und so weiter die man ja gar nicht
beeinflussen kann das weiß man ja oft
vorher gar nicht wie macht man das dass
man da wirklich so genau an Punkt landet
weil die wissen ja genau muss ich
hinkommen einerseits gibt es eine sehr
sehr gute militärische Wetterberatung
dass man das eine das heißt über die
Winde müssen die Fallschirmspringer grob
Bescheid wissen wie wir finden ihn
Verhältnisse sind über der Stadt ist das
ja noch dann eine zusätzliche
Herausforderung hier gibt es dann
Umständen vor allem im niedrigeren
Bereich die
die Fallschirme sind lenkbar das heißt
da fällt nicht gerade herunter sondern
ja schon kann schon sehr gut steuern wo
er wo er hinsprengt man sieht jetzt hier
das kleine Transportflugzeug hat mal
kurz gesehen
aus dem sie abgesetzt werden und
wir haben erst vor
wenigen Monaten einen einen Versuch
durchgeführtes ja Kommando ist am
Wienerberg auf den Hochhäusern am Dach
gelandet und das ist schon spezielle
Leistung aber dort nochmals die
Windverhältnisse anders sind als auf
einer freien Fläche Wille mit dem
Heldenplatz wie lange dauert das jetzt
bis die Fallschirmspringer kommen etwa
vier Minuten dauert es vom Absetzen bis
zur Landung
auch Bilder sehen vom vom Abflug wie sie
ab 5 Jahren Soldaten haben wir auch
Fahnen jeweils dabei
auch besser sehen können
die die Soldaten des jahrkommandos sind
sind ja im Endeffekt alle in im
Fallschirmspringen und entsprechend
ausgebildet und natürlich gibt es dort
Spezialisierungen in verschiedenste
Richtungen und dann die Meisterklasse im
falschen springen ist dann eine
gesonderte davon und was sind das für
Fahnen die da die sende Europafahne die
österreichfahne die Fahne Wiens und die
Fahne mit dem Symbol des Jagdkommandos
werden die Soldaten drauf von diese vier
Minuten ergeben sich auch aus dem dass
er
zuerst einmal die beiden also die drei
Flugzeuge abfliegen mussten und bevor
man den verhältnismäßig kleineren das
verhältnismäßig kleinere Flugzeug
Dateien bringen kann damit dort keine
verwebelungen mehr sein muss man ja die
ein bisschen auseinanderhalten wie weit
sind die auseinander die Flugzeuge also
oder wie springen die hintereinander ab
oder oder die Soldaten T4 die springen
hin hintereinander gleich also einer
nach dem anderen aus dem Flugzeug und
die die Trennung zwischen dem Flugzeug
mit dem Fallschirmspringen und der den
Eurofighters unter 1030 das war sowohl
der Höhe mäßig wie auch von der Zeit her
und in welchem Abstand also jetzt hüpft
der erste Soldat hinaus
möglich damit die entsprechend
nahe beieinander bleiben weil die ja
dann auch
möglichst mit geringen Abständen am
Heldenplatz landen sollen kann das auch
passieren dass dass man sich da
irgendwie gegenseitig in der Luft
begegnet und oder sind ist man da sehr
wer auseinander also das wäre jedenfalls
zu vermeiden und die Soldaten sind schon
so ausgebildet dass sie ihre Abstände
einhalten können und
beides natürlich lebensgefährlich wäre
wenn man in der Luft hier einen
Zusammenstoß hätte vor allem wenn dann
da Fallschirm einmal geöffnet ist also
das ist dann lebensgefährlich hier sehen
wir sie jetzt kommen die im Bild
die viereckigen rot-weiß-roten
Fallschirme und einen grünen
das sind wir erwähnt lenkbare
Fallschirme damit sie entsprechend eine
Punktlandung hinbekommen und die machen
das ja nicht so ein Tollerei oder um das
vorführen zu können sondern im
Wesentlichen sind es ja Aufgaben der
Spezialeinsatzkräfte die
aber ist trotzdem beeindruckend für die
ZuseherInnen
aber die müssten das ja auch bei Nacht
und schlechter Sicht oder auch im
Gebirge machen können was dann noch
einmal eine größere Herausforderung
darstellt wie lange wird man da
ausgebildet also
fertig ist von mittergrundausbildung mal
eineinhalb Jahre und dann ist er ganz
fertig ist drei Jahre und dann wird noch
weiter spezialisiert also wenn sie dann
Taucher werden oder
andere
Spezialgebiete belegen geht die
Ausbildung immer weiter und für eine
Kommando Soldaten der im operativen
geschehen ist ist eigentlich die
Ausbildung zu Ende
also ich auch technologisch sehr viel
tut neue Funkgeräte neues Systeme wo man
einfach drauf bleiben muss
wie lange dauert das jetzt noch unten
sind also Minute
brauchen werden
sehr gut
also wir halten natürlich ihre
Sicherheitsbestimmungen ein aber sie
schauen natürlich auch dass das alles
gut abläuft und gut sichtbar ist für die
Zuschauer
vielleicht erwarten noch zum
Jagdkommando die stehen ja im Einsatz
weltweit wer noch für die weltweiten
Einsätze ausgebildet waren lange in
Afghanistan sind jetzt im Mali und sind
natürlich die die Speerspitze so wie es
auch im Video
gezeigt wurde unseres Bundesheeres das
haben die ersten die wo hineingehen oder
bei einer überkühlungsoperation auch die
letzten hinausgehen und jetzt sind wir
schon die Landung
und jetzt gibt es
in der Bundesliga hat man auch nicht
jeden Tag ja
wir dürfen uns an dieser Stelle schon
verabschieden danke Hans Bürger danke
generalmaier Bruno Hofbauer für ihre
umfassende Expertise an der sie uns
haben teilhaben lassen ja und Ihnen zu
Hause dürfen wir hier noch einen schönen
Nationalfeiertag wünschen